bonjour à tous hier soir les sénateurs
ont poursuivi l'examen du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014 ils ont d'abord conclu la
discussion générale ce moment où les
différents sénateurs se succèdent à la
tribune afin d'exprimer les opinions des
différents groupes politiques puis ils
ont enchaîné sur l'examen de la première
et de la deuxième partie du texte
respectivement consacrée à l'approbation
des contes pour 2012 et au comte 2013 si
la première partie a été adoptée la
seconde a été en revanche rejetée
puisque les communistes ont uni leur
voix à la droite pour rejeter ce texte
c'est donc ce moment que je vous propose
de revoir ce matin
la parole est à Monsieur René Paul
Savary pour le groupe UMP
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mais cher
collègue mon intervention Portra au nom
de notre groupe sur la politique
médicale
au sein de ce PDFs et plus
principalement pour marquer l'absence de
proposition pour clarifier les les
relations entre partenaires par exemple
entre l'État les caisses d'assurance
maladie et bien sûr les les conseils
généraux et cela est particulièrement
flagrant me semble-t-il en ce qui
concerne la politique de la famille et
la politique de de la dépendance donc je
vais en premier parler de la famille
notamment à propos de l'article 45 pour
lequel nous proposerons un certain
nombre d'amendements vous voyez madame
la ministre nous avons des propositions
à faire il est temps de clarifier les
les rapports
entre assurance maladie et conseils
généraux notamment en ce qui concerne la
protection maternelle et infantile
les caisses d'assurance maladie doivent
prendre en compte dans leur nomenclature
les actes médicaux et paramédicaux
réalisés par les professionnels de santé
de la Protection Maternelle et Infantile
par exemple est normal que le
renouvellement de la contraception ou
les vaccins ne soient pas pris en charge
au même taux que leur ce qu'ils sont
prescrits dans le cadre de la médecine
de ville la médecine hospitalière et
donc sont donc mis sur le dos des
conseils généraux là aussi des charges
supplémentaires des dépenses sanitaires
dont ils n'ont pas directement la
compétence un autre exemple et on
l'illustrera également à travers des
amendements sur l'article 59 c'est le
Front national de la protection de
l'enfance
je voulais rappeler une fois encore je
m'en excuse mais c'est important parfois
de rabâcher si l'on veut arriver assez
fins je voulais rappeler que les
étrangers mineurs isolés présentent une
charge annuelle de l'ordre de 250
millions d'euros pour les conseils
généraux ce n'est pas les présidents
sénateurs ici présents qui me
contrediront bien entendu et
l'immigration s'accroît quand même de
façon significative et c'est bien d'une
politique de l'État dont il s'agit
puisque plus que d'une politique
familiale preuve en ex c'est que c'est
madame la garde des sceaux qui mène la
négociation avec les départements le
flux actuel je tiens à le rappeler est
atteint les les 4000 mineurs étrangers
isolés par an actuellement par rapport à
8000 qui sont résidents en France nous
sommes bien loin rappelons-le des 1500
qui ont été proposés à la répartition
entre départements et c'est à l'État
nous semble-t-il d'assurer leur prise en
charge en s'appuyant sur les conseils
généraux et non l'inverse d'ailleurs
Jean arthuri doit proposer bientôt une
une loi qui me paraît intéressante et je
vous inviterai bien sûr à le suivre en
ce qui concerne cette politique très
spécifique maintenant en ce qui concerne
les personnes dépendantes notre groupe
fera également des propositions à
travers des amendements si nous allons
bien sûr jusqu'à l'examen des rapports
sur les sur les dépenses en ce qui
concerne la contribution de solidarité
active je crois que comme son nom
l'indique elle est réservée pour le
financement de la dépendance plus que
pour sa partie plus pour sa partie
médico-sociale pardon que pour sa partie
sanitaire
de même que les caisses d'assurance
maladie sont faites pour prendre en
charge et dépenses pour la maladie alors
que il revient au conseil général par le
biais de là-bas de prendre en charge les
dépenses correspondant à la dépendance
donc notre groupe présentera et Alain
Milon l'a déjà brillamment annoncé un
amendement pour que le les fonds de la
contribution additionnelle pour la
solidarité et l'autonomie soit affecter
à l'aide pour l'autonomie en totalité
par le biais de la contribution
nationale de solidarité active bien sûr
et je partage ses propos il y en a assez
de ces détournements de fonds aux dépens
des conseils généraux nous ferons
également madame la ministre un certain
nombre de propositions de coordination
de la dépense publique notamment pour
maîtriser la masse salariale dans les
équipements médico-sociaux où nous
soutiendrons des amendements visant à
accorder une primauté aux articles du
code de l'action sociale et de la
famille par rapport aux article
concernant la procédure d'agrément des
conventions collectives car il s'agit là
de la maîtrise de la masse salariale qui
doit être envisagée de façon plus
précise si on veut véritablement en
assurer la responsabilité de même ceux
qui concerne la pas vous le savez bien
elle est devenue trop lourde insupporter
budgétairement pour les départements il
sera donc proposé en 2014 de maintenir
les montants de l'objectif global des
dépenses prévues d'ailleurs par le
gouvernement pour mieux compenser les
dépenses d'appât des départements et à
ce sujet rappelons que les propositions
du plfs du PLF qui va être examinés dans
quelques semaines sont particulièrement
décevantes ce qui concerne c'est
compensations de la solidarité je ne
suis pas sûr que les engagements qui ont
été pris soit véritablement tenu
maintenant des propositions d'économies
deux abonnements là aussi important
qui relèvera de la mutualisation des
appels à projets dans le cadre de la
transformation pour extension des
capacités des équipements médicaux
sociaux et un deuxième qui vise à
réaliser des économies notamment en
permettant à plusieurs services
complémentaires de gérer par le même
organisme gestionnaire de proposer de
procéder pardon à une évaluation externe
commune en conclusion je voudrais dire
que ce qui REC caractérise se perfss
pour 2014 comme d'ailleurs celui de l'an
dernier c'est toujours plus de
prélèvement pas plus de services rendus
aucune clarification quant à la
répartition des compétences et des coûts
toujours une absence de volonté de
rechercher des économies pourtant
indispensables afin de pouvoir proposer
notamment la loi sur l'autonomie et
pourtant le réalisme budgétaire devrait
l'emporter sur l'idéalisme
plutôt que de critiquer Tiron expérience
des initiatives avortées ou mal perçues
telles la loi sur l'autonomie abandonnée
il y a quelques années ou celle sur les
retraites rejetées il y a seulement
quelques semaines pour être clair madame
la ministre l'absence de prévisions
budgétaire pour la loi sur l'autonomie
fait redouter un jugement sans appel par
le Sénat jugement sensiblement identique
à celui porté sur les retraites 346
contre 0 les bonnes intentions ne
suffisent pas toujours et le père FSS va
être soumis à une sanction venant de
tout bord et vous le savez madame le
ministre quand une loi n'est pas
acceptée par les sénateurs elle a
probablement toutes les chances de ne
pas être accepté par nos concitoyens et
encore moins supportés par les
contribuables je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Laurence Rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues j'avais eu l'occasion au
cours du débat sur le projet de loi
égalité femme homme de m'inquiéter de la
détérioration des conditions d'accès à
l'IVG et de la persistance voire même de
la résurgence d'un climat hostile à
l'IVG dans des milieux intégristes
parfois présents au sein des services
hospitaliers et je n'évoque pas là je ne
vise pas là les patientes ou leur mari
mais je vise des équipes médicales le
Haut Conseil à l'égalité a remis la
semaine dernière à Madame
Vallaud-Belkacem un rapport relatif à
l'accès à l'IVG dans les territoires ce
rapport
identifie une série d'obstacles et
formule plusieurs propositions
la loi veille peut-être commençons par
ce qu'on pourrait appeler la dissuasion
les ce qui relève de la dissuasion la
loi veille qui évoque l'état de détresse
de la femme qui demande une IVG
c'est la loi veille impose un délai de
réflexion de 7 jours et réserve au
personnels médicaux une clause de
conscience spécifique aux IVG alors que
la possibilité de recours à la clause de
conscience existe déjà pour tous les
personnels soignants et pour l'ensemble
des actes médicaux
on peut comprendre qu'au moment de
l'adoption de la loi veille pour
laquelle rappelons-le le vote des
parlementaires de gauche avait été
déterminant le ministre la ministre
n'ayant pas le soutien de sa majorité et
du faire quelques concessions
aujourd'hui ces concessions n'ont plus
lieu d'être le consensus politique a
progressé les passions si on accepte
les passions si on excepte des
groupuscules certit hyperactif mais fort
marginaux se sont apaisés
l'approche culpabilisante de l'IVG peut
donc disparaître personne ne peut ni
juger ni imposer à une femme un état de
détresse pour avoir recours à une IVG et
il n'a pas davantage d'assignation à la
souffrance des femmes qui avortent pour
certaines c'est une douleur et pour
d'autres non
mais rien si ce n'est la volonté de
provoquer et d'entretenir la culpabilité
ne justifie que cette notion de détresse
reste dans la loi
de même les femmes qui avortent son
maître de leur choix et le délai de 7
jours de réflexion est une disposition
spécifique et infantilisante
pas davantage la double cause de
conscience n'est désormais de
justification
le rapport du Haut Conseil à l'égalité
identifie dans certains territoires un
parcours d'accès IVG difficile pouvant
déboucher sur des dépassements de délai
et une obligation de pratiquer l'IVG à
l'étranger
l'offre de soins qui s'est dégradé à la
fois victime de la fermeture de 130
IVG au cours des 10 dernières années et
d'une démographie médicale vieillissante
et moins militante ne garantit pas
aujourd'hui à toutes les femmes qui en
ont besoin ni un accès rapide et à
proximité d'une IVG ni le choix et la
méthode de l'IVG d'anesthésie ni la
gratuité ni la confidentialité
parmi les recommandations du Haut
Conseil à l'égalité j'en ai retenu
quelques-unes qui relèvent directement
madame la ministre de votre compétence
et de l'organisation de l'offre de soins
pour contourner les problèmes de
démographie médicale ou de résistance
idéologique il est temps de permettre à
des personnels non médecins de délivrer
la première attestation
j'ajouterai qu'on pourrait comme elle le
sujet en d'ailleurs elle-même ouvrir au
sage-femmes le droit de pratiquer l'IVG
médicamenteuse
deux autres propositions me semblent
devoir être également soutenu faire
respecter l'article
r224 du code de la santé publique qui
impose la pratique de l'IVG à tous les
établissements disposant d'un service de
gynécologie et ou de chirurgie et en
complément il est nécessaire d'attribuer
à l'activité IVG les moyens financiers
nécessaires la procédure contractuelle
nous permettrait d'avancer enfin la
réflexion doit continuer je ne la
tranche pas sur les questions soit de
revalorisation du forfait soit de
déforphétisation de l'acte d'IVG
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
l'IVG et somme toute un événement assez
courant dans la vie d'une femme il
concerne une femme sur trois à un moment
donné de sa vie sans distinction d'âge
sans distinction de milieu social sans
distinction philosophique mais il
demeure néanmoins toujours un droit à
part 40 ans après la loi veille il est
temps que l'IVG soit juste un droit
juste un droit garanti à toutes les
femmes
déculpabiliser les femmes des dramatiser
les choix des marginaliser la pratique
médicale voilà ce qu'il nous reste
encore à faire et que je souhaite avec
beaucoup de mes collègues voir figurer
prochainement dans un projet de loi je
vous remercie merci
la parole est à Monsieur Gérard Larcher
pour le groupe UMP
dans la parole monsieur
le Président Madame la Ministre madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
il y a 5 ans au nom de la mission
hôpital je présentais à la demande du
Président de la République Nicolas
Sarkozy un rapport sur l'émission de
l'hôpital public
après une vaste concertation notre
objectif était de garantir à tous les
Français un service de santé de qualité
offrant en toute sécurité des soins
accessibles à tous
de long des bas ensuite ont été
nécessaires pour adopter cette loi
Hôpital Patient Santé et territoire et
Alain Milo a été ici notre rapporteur
l'objectif qui était le nôtre demeure
aujourd'hui attaque donner un CAP et un
sens à la politique hospitalière et lui
offrir une ambition cette ambition se
capte cette vision sont-ils aujourd'hui
au rendez-vous permettez-moi madame la
ministre je constate en effet avec
beaucoup d'autres qu'il s'agissent des
représentants des professionnels de
santé des différentes fédérations ou
encore du monde libéral industriel
mutualiste et assurantielle que les
mesures inscrites dans ce texte sont en
décalage par rapport aux objectifs
recherchés quelques illustrations me
semblent suffire à son convaincre tout
d'abord l'évolution de la tarification à
l'activité
le gouvernement nous dit que le système
de tarification n'est pas adapté à la
coopération des établissements et des
professionnels de santé pas plus qu'au
travail en réseau et en filière je peux
partager ce constat mais alors où est la
réforme ambitieuse du modèle de
tarification nous l'évoquions ici il y a
un an ce projet de loi se contente en
fait de mesure ponctuelles complexes
souvent technocratique et parfois très
idéologique à la manière du dispositif
relatif à la décrécivité tarifaire comme
le démontré encore récemment nos
collègues mylon et le Maine le véritable
enjeu et de construire un modèle de
financement d'ailleurs
pluriannuel de prise en charge
coordonnées à l'échelle d'un territoire
et je milite pour que des
expérimentations à échelle suffisante
soient menées sur une ou plusieurs
intérêts
l'investissement est une question
majeure investir c'est préparer l'avenir
aujourd'hui le choix qui est fait et
celui du gel les investissements
hospitaliers puisque les sommes mis sur
la table ne vont pas suffire au
renouvellement courant des bâtiments et
matériels mais surtout madame le
ministre je voudrais savoir pourquoi le
gouvernement a choisi de centraliser les
décisions d'investissement et de les
confier à des instances bureaucratiques
qui nous font passer à des décennies en
arrière le comité interministériel de
performance et de la modernisation de
l'offre de soins sans la présence des
élus du territoire et sans la présence
des Hospitaliers le tel choix ne veut
pas reste pas de bonne augure d'autant
plus que cette situation financière
patrimoniale est aggravée par les choix
idéologiques fait par le gouvernement
dans la loi du flot
véritable OPA sur le patrimoine dont son
propriétaire les hôpitaux d'ailleurs qui
pose la question est-ce qu'un hôpital
est un établissement public local ou
national sujet que le rapport pécheur
semble traiter comme national alors que
ce n'était pas l'intention du
législateur nous ne pouvons pas mes
chers collègues nous au Sénat dont la
préoccupation doit être le territoire en
quelque sorte ne pas avoir un débat sur
le statut la situation des
établissements publics de santé sont-ils
locaux territoriaux où sont-ils
nationaux c'est me semble-t-il un sujet
majeur parce que nous avons le sentiment
que le texte en texte c'est le
territoire qu'on abandonne
progressivement dans le cadre d'une
forme de recentralisation qui m'apparaît
extrêmement
dangereuse il nous faut donc
quel que soit la responsabilité des uns
et des autres pardonnez-moi la loi HP St
n’a jamais prévu que les établissements
publics soient
décrété comme nationaux j'enseigné en
moi quelque chose pour avoir préparé les
prémices de ce texte au-delà de cette de
ce texte la question que je pose
aujourd'hui et celui de la cohérence et
de l'ambition de la politique
hospitalière et médico-social j'aurais
souligné la pauvreté
l'oubli du secteur de la santé mentale
quand traître en quelque sorte comme
l'ancien hôpital général il nous faut
nos chers collègues mes chers collègues
vous interrogé tous sur cette question
de la situation de la santé mentale dans
notre pays alors notre système de santé
me paraît de voir aujourd'hui répondre
plutôt un système de confiance que de
méfiance j'ai bien le sentiment que
c'est la méfiance qui est le sujet le
plus important voilà pourquoi je réclame
le droit à l'expérimentation mais aussi
une réflexion sur les régional de santé
qu'elle ne soit pas j'allais dire un
exercice bureaucratique de plus mais un
vrai régulateur un vrai facilitateur
pour s'occuper de l'essentiel enfin d'un
mot mes chers collègues puisque le tant
tourne je voudrais madame la ministre a
tirer votre attention sur la situation
des établissements de santé
ultra marin je dois vous dire pour jeudi
savoir eu des responsabilités nationales
dans le domaine hospitaliers ou dire que
ces établissements et leur spécificité
me paraissent aujourd'hui négligée alors
même qu'il remplisse une mission
essentielle dans nos départements et nos
territoires voilà pourquoi je souhaite
qu'une cellule interministérielle dédiée
au suivi au soutien de ces
établissements puissent être mis en
place un auvergence dans son rapport
innovation 2030
écrivez que la santé sera au cœur des
innovations de demain sous réserve et je
cite que ce secteur soit suffisamment
valorisé qu'une politique cohérente en
matière de recherche et de soutien aux
innovations soit menées voilà pourquoi
tout ceci me paraît beaucoup plus
important que de relancer les guéguères
permanentes entre public et privés ce
qui compte c'est de répondre d'une
manière financièrement soutenable aux
besoins de santé des Françaises et les
Français c'est ça l'enjeu me semble-t-il
d'un projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre Charron
pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le président
madame la ministre
monsieur les rapporteurs les chers
collègues
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 est une fois
de plus
symptomatique de la politique d'un
gouvernement socialiste à la française
les entreprises et les contribuables
sont plumés et les épargnants et les
investisseurs sont dépouillés pour
redresser les comptes sociaux le
gouvernement a une fois encore choisi
d'alourdir la fiscalité alors que nous
devrions
concentrer nos efforts sur une baisse de
la dépense publique pour suivre des
réformes de structure pour enrayer la
spirale infernale de la dette le
mécontentement pend des Français grondes
fermeture d'usine chômage aux élastiques
ce sont plus de 94 mesures fiscales et
sociales que l'exécutif a mis en œuvre
principalement à la hausse depuis juin
2012 qui s'apparente à un matraquage et
qui contribue à exaspération devant
laquelle vous ne pouvez davantage rester
inerte perte de confiance et angoisse
légitime des familles s'accentue donnant
le sentiment aux français mais aussi à
nos voisins européens que nous habitons
un bateau ivre cherchant à gratter
partout vous avez décidé et fait adopter
des mesures fiscales rétroactives
jusqu'en 1997 dans un premier temps sur
tous les produits d'épargne auto-unique
de 15,5 PEA PEL et Paris salarial
assurance vie de quoi semer un trouble
durable chez les épargnants devant la et
après vous être obstiné en séance
publique à alourdir les prélèvements
sociaux sur les produits de placement
vous avez reculé pour annoncer que seul
l'assurance vie et ses contrats
multisports prisés par 7 millions
d'épargnants seront concernés par le
projet mais c'est encore trop et comble
de l'insupportable curieusement vous
avez annoncé à la va-vite que la mesure
s'appliquait déjà avant même d'être voté
à compter du mois de septembre dernier
pour éviter tout comportement
d'optimisation
anticipative nous contestons la mesure
pour plusieurs raisons tout d'abord du
point de vue de sa lisibilité son aspect
rétroactif a pour désastreuse
conséquence la rupture du pacte de
confiance entre gouvernants et
administré et l'encre l'idée d'une
instabilité fiscale et l'esplaner comme
l'épée de Damoclès rappelé par le
questeur d'herio la possibilité à tout
moment d'augmenter rétroactivement les
prélèvements sociaux trop de Français
quittent la France déjà 35
lassé par cette fiscalité confiscatoire
et entravé dans leur liberté
d'entreprendre elle met à mal la
pédagogie de vos prédécesseurs visant à
faire de l'assurance vie une source de
financement d'amélioration des retraites
d'une part et d'autre part une réserve
de capitaux visant à financer les
entreprises françaises elle donne le
signal d'un sacrifice de l'épargne à
long terme au profit de l'épargne à
court terme il y a une incohérence sur
laquelle vous ne pouvez fermer les yeux
le privilège serait accordé au contrat
mono-support dont la contribution au
financement des fonds propres des
entreprises françaises sera de plus en
plus faible au détriment des contrats
multisports investis en partie en fonds
à la veille de la création d'un nouveau
contrat euro croissance destiné à
orienter l'épargne vers le financement
des fonds propres entreprises
l'instabilité fiscale est juridique la
perception que peuvent avoir les
épargnants de ces mesures spoliatrices
ne peuvent que fragiliser son démarrage
enfin si la rétroactivité fiscale
imposée par la mesure pose un problème
d'égalité entre les contribuables
s'ajoute un problème d'iniquité entre
les détenteurs de contrats monocytor et
ceux des contrats multisports investis
en fond garanties pour l'investissement
sur un même fond les environs
s'appliqués les prélèvements sociaux au
fil de l'eau au taux de chaque année les
autres au moment du retrait ou au décès
au dernier taux connus dont on peut
parier qu'il sera toujours plus élevé de
telles dispositions ne peuvent rétablir
la confiance encourager les
investisseurs les investisseurs pardon
qu'il se détourne de notre pays elles
asphyxie notre économie ce sont des
mesures incompréhensibles en parfaite
contradiction avec les engagements pris
par le Premier ministre lui-même en
faveur des placements dirigés par le
financement des entreprises la
compétitivité
l'investissement et le développement
durable débattre du projet de loi du
financement de la sécurité sociale est
une prérogative majeure du Parlement
nous devrions prendre nos
responsabilités pour permettre à la
solidarité nationale de s'exercer tout
en sauvegardant les équilibres
financiers en réalité ce pelvss allonge
une liste de nouvelles charges fiscales
c'est de la facilité en faisant peser la
majorité des mesures d'économie sur le
médicament qui leur présente que 15% des
dépenses de santé en revanche les
réformes de structure se font encore
attendre sur la carte hospitalière
l'offre de soins la spécialisation les
établissements la question des désirs
médicaux bref ce texte n'est pas à la
hauteur loin sans faux c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous ne le voterons pas je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues
Dassault pour le groupe UMP
monsieur le Président Madame ministre
monsieur rapporteur chers collègues
madame la musique je crois que je vais
vous faire plaisir
en effet vous proposez le combler le
déficit de la Sécurité sociale dans ce
téléphone qui se porte à des milliards
en utilisant une fonction de loi que
j'ai fait déposer au bureau du Sénat et
qu'ils appliquent que l'entreprise
marchande car utilisant le chiffre
d'affaires dans ces calculs
c'est à dire c'est pas l'administration
cette proposition de loi
permettrait en effet le supprimer des
charges sur salaire les charges maladies
et familles qui sont considérables et
qui elles seront prises en charge par
les frais généraux des entreprises
marchandes ce sont toujours les
entreprises qui payeront c'est à dire
qu'il n'y aura pas de participation et
de l'État ni de contribuable ni de
sévère et cela permettra de réduire les
chats sur salaires ayant uniquement le
chômage et la retraite de
55%, ce qui est considérable et
augmentera de façon importante la
compétitivité de toute entreprise
comment payer le reste
et bien voilà je vous propose que chaque
entreprise
paiera ses charges maladie et famille
enfin généraux et pas sur le salaire et
en fonction de nos questions d'activité
qui sera calculée et favorisant les
entreprises de main d'oeuvre et l'emploi
le calcul de ce que fission ce sera par
la formule suivante
évidemment il faudrait que vous ayez
la reproduction ce que fission
multiplier par chiffre d'affaires moi la
masse salariale de chaque entreprise
sera égal au montant de charge maladie
et famille qui devra payer
mais si on fait le total ce coefficient
aujourd'hui peut être calculée de façon
nationale en utilisant la totalité des
charges manières familles c'est à dire
217 milliards
mais si grâce à ce coalition on augmente
le résultat de 10 milliards c'est à dire
de 227 milliards ce qui supprimerait
complètement la le déficit de la social
on augmentera légèrement ce que fichier
et grâce à
plusieurs entreprises aura de salariés
moins elle payera de charges et se fera
favorisera les entreprises de main
d'oeuvre c'est à dire l'emploi et
défavorisera par contre les entreprises
de services qui réalisent un gros
chiffre d'affaires avec peu de
personnels mais aussi toutes ces
entreprises qui prennent qui achètent à
l'étranger ou qui délocalise et qui ont
de leur chiffre d'affaires n'ont pas de
salaire que les salaires sont payés en
dehors de France
vous aurez ainsi un équilibre de votre
budget et on crée aussi ainsi un nouvel
impôt effectivement qui fait à la charge
d'entreprise marchande mais avec une
assiette très large et un faible
coefficient dont une légère augmentation
amènera un grand produit fiscal
ce serait un nouvel impôts j'en sais
rien mais qui ne serait pas lié à la
consommation mais la production et qui
pourrait être aussi utilisé comme un
nouveau droit de douane car en fait
c'est un pot ça sera tous ces
importations et tous les délocalisations
cette opération fait l'objet d'une
pollution de loi que je déposais au
bureau de Sénat et qui vous sera proposé
en début de janvier là actuellement
étudié par une commission d'études de
sénateur créé à cet effet pour étudier
les conséquences de cette proposition
dans divers secteurs d'activités de
haute valeur ajoutée en effet un effort
de compatibilité de rectangle des
personnels peut amener une augmentation
de charge dans ce cas on pour adapter si
nécessaire ce que mission d'activité a
des productions à forte valeur ajoutée
voilà Mesdames ce que je voulais vous
dire pour vous informer je vais prendre
un tirer cette promotion pour
l'équilibre des dépenses de la sécurité
sociale et de votre budget je vous
remercie merci chers
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe pour
le groupe UMP
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
monsieur de ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales et mes chers collègues
tout à l'heure notre collègue Serge
Dassault madame la ministre a souhaité
vous êtes agréable je ne voudrais pas
que vous pensiez que je souhaite vous
êtes désagréable je voudrais donc
d'abord commencer par quelques propos
qui je l'espère pourront faire
l'unanimité je voudrais vous dire tout
d'abord que c'est vrai que l'exercice
des lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale est un exercice souvent décevant
et finalement ça n'est pas si mal parce
que s'il est décevons c'est que notre
sécurité sociale va plutôt mieux qu'il
est convenu de le dire
nous avons un système dont on répète
assez souvent et à juste titre qu'il est
au cœur du pacte républicain
pour ce qui concerne la santé nos
indicateurs de santé sont parmi les
meilleurs du monde pour ce qui concerne
la famille nous avons plus de 800 000
enfants qui naissent chaque année en
France avec un taux de natalité parmi
les meilleurs d'Europe et pour ce qui
concerne enfin la vieillesse n'oublions
pas tout de même que le revenu moyen de
nos retraités ce qui n'élimine pas les
écarts parfois très importants est
aujourd'hui très proche de celui des
actifs une bonne sécurité sociale ça
mérite quand même d'être souligné
une bonne sécurité sociale aussi quand
on compare finalement les résultats de
la gestion de la sécurité sociale au
résultat de la gestion des contes de
l'État on voit à quel point notre
sécurité sociale marche mieux que l'État
les déficits de la Sécurité sociale sont
très faibles comparés à ceux de l'État
et représente 15% des déficits publics
et ceux de l'État
85%. et donc quand on voit effectivement
les forts de réduction des déficits que
nous devons collectivement accomplir il
est juste de dire que sans négliger le
nécessaire redressement des cônes de la
sécurité sociale et doit porter d'abord
et avant tout sur la dépense publique de
l'État alors évidemment ça
ne nous exonère pas ne vous exonère pas
de votre responsabilité en matière de
réduction des déficits
il est pas mauvais
de souligner les désaccords qu'il y a
entre nous et le gouvernement car après
tout l'expression
assumée de désaccord c'est quand même
l'hygiène de la démocratie
si on regarde ce qui est au cœur de
notre désaccord c'est l'impôt
et on le voit bien dans ce dans ce texte
au fond vous êtes assez à l'aise
avec l'impôt pourvu que vous puissiez
assumer de dire qu'il est juste et nous
sommes généralement assez mal à l'aise
avec la peau dès lors qu'il pénalise
l'activité à l'emploi et nous
considérons que c'est le cas avec bon
nombre des prélèvements que vous
réunissez dans ce texte comme vous
l'avez fait dans d'autres textes comme
vous le faites dans le projet de loi de
finance initial pour
2014 j'aurais peut-être l'occasion
d'y revenir dans un instant mais enfin
ce que vous faites pour les artisans
pour nous c'est pas quelque chose qui
d'autre puisse se prévaloir alors qu'on
parle aujourd'hui tant de la nécessité
d'améliorer la compétitivité je
reviendrai sur d'autres prélèvements
l'industrie pharmaceutique n'est tout de
même pas une vache à lait chaque année
je vois qu'on alourdit encore les
prélèvements sur l'industrie
pharmaceutique alors il y a des
désaccords
sur vos choix il y a aussi pour nous un
des accords fondamental qui tient à vos
non choix et dans ce texte comme l'ont
appelé beaucoup de mes collègues il y a
trop de non choix alors bien sûr il y a
la trace de cette réforme cosmétique des
retraites dont nous avons débattu la
semaine dernière pour la rejeter à
l'unanimité on ne peut même pas parler
de réformes tellement cette ce texte
manquait de substances il y a le renvoi
au calendes grec de l'indispensable
réforme de la prise en charge de la
dépendance
il y a un manque
de réflexion sur une réforme
structurelle de l'Assurance Maladie
pourtant bien nécessaire et notamment
pour combattre les déserts médicaux et
puis alors il y a sur la famille
un démantèlement méthodique de notre
politique familiale en ce qui concerne à
la fois le quotient familial et les
prestations avec lesquelles nous ne
serions être d'accord et votre mesure
par exemple sur la fiscalisation des
avantages familiaux de retraite est une
mesure pour nous une acceptable car les
parents de famille nombreuses n'ont pas
les mêmes moyens que les autres pour se
constituer un patrimoine alors même que
leurs enfants vont contribuer à la
retraite des autres et c'est donc une
mesure de justice que vous avez remise
en cause ce qui nous paraît
véritablement un franchissement de ligne
rouge
il y a ça il y a aussi un certain nombre
d'insuffisances graves je trouve que ce
que vous faites sur le médico-social je
n'ai jamais vu des chiffres aussi bas
alors que les besoins de nos personnages
je parlais de la dépendance et de nos
personnes handicapées sont souvent si
criants et que nos départements ont des
finances aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas
compenser le déclin de l'effort de la
puissance publique sur le financement
médico-social alors là je trouve que
être passé comme vous le faites pour
2014 à un nom d'âme médico-social
personne âgée de 2,9 et personne
handicapées de 3,1 c'est tout simplement
pas bien et je crois que si l'uniops la
dénoncé avec tant de vigueur ça n'est
pas sans raison et je crois que vous
auriez intérêt à revoir en toute
conscience cet aspect de votre texte et
puis enfin et c'est pas
une question secondaire une question de
loyauté vis-à-vis des Français moi je
crois vraiment que la dimension morale
doit être
avancé d'abord sur les prélèvements
obligatoires tout de même vous nous avez
dit l'année dernière tu es les
prélèvements obligatoires nous
manqueraient plus c'est pour seulement
vous le président de la République la
fête aussi ils augmentent ensuite sur
les mesures
rétroactivité de la taxation de
l'épargne tourne de passe-passe sur la
contribution additionnelle de solidarité
pour l'autonomie vous demandez aux
Français retraités de l'argent pour
l'autonomie
et vous le donnez au fond de solidarité
vieillesse qui doit être financé par
l'impôt pour payer les cotisations de
retraite des chômeurs mais c'est
scandaleux
vous devez entendre cela car c'est ce
qui se dit sur le terrain et les
Français ne peuvent pas l'admettre et
puis je parlais de la fiscalisation des
avantages familiaux de retraite je
parlerai aussi du forfait social
complémentaire santé qui sera augmentée
si les recommandations sur le choix d'un
assureur complémentaire dans le cadre
d'un accord de travail ne sont pas
respectés tout ceci qui bafoune décision
du Conseil constitutionnel ça n'est pas
acceptable et c'est pourquoi Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre avec toute
la bonne volonté du monde et avec
l'amour je dirais que j'ai pour notre
sécurité sociale je considère que ce
texte qui ne fait pas un grand tort à
notre sécurité sociale comporte quand
même un certain nombre de mesures qui
sont totalement inacceptables nous
sommes en désaccord sur l'augmentation
des prélèvements obligatoires nous
sommes en désaccord sur un certain
nombre de vos choix nous sommes en
désaccord sur vos non-soi nous sommes
très négatifs sur les insuffisances de
votre texte pour répondre à de vrais
besoins et nous pensons vous manquer de
loyauté à l'égard des Français dans un
certain nombre de dispositions qui
relèvent de véritables tours de
passe-passe
merci cher collègue
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à la Marisol Tourel ministre des
Affaires sociales et de la santé
si monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
quelques mots pour réagir
au diverses interventions qui viennent
de se dérouler à l'occasion de du début
de ce débat sur le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
permettez-moi tout d'abord de saluer la
qualité du travail de l'ensemble des
rapporteurs et une fois encore de
marquer tout particulièrement
l'investissement de monsieur le
rapporteur général Yves de Digny et je
voudrais le remercier en particulier
ainsi que le rapporteur pour avis
Jean-Pierre café d'avoir appelé que ce
texte a comme priorité la consolidation
de la solidarité nationale et le
redressement durable de nos comptes
parce que j'ai entendu sur les bancs de
l'opposition un certain nombre
d'interventions expliquant que et encore
à l'instant monsieur bas mais tout à
l'heure monsieur Milon Cardou expliquant
que au fond nous n'étions là que pour
demander de nouveaux efforts de nouveaux
prélèvements comme s'il n'y avait pas 4
milliards d'euros d'économies qui pour
la première fois venait apporter ou
reconstituer une étape très
significative dans le redressement de
nos comptes sociaux et j'aurais préféré
ou pour dire les choses autrement votre
vos leçons de finances publiques ou vos
leçons de morale pour reprendre la
formulation de Monsieur bas
ustté plus convaincante si au cours des
dernières années vous nous aviez
vous-même marqué le chemin parce que
nous entendons à longueur de débat que
vous avez été confrontés à la crise mais
je voudrais vous rappeler que la crise
elle n'a pas dominé l'ensemble des
années 2000 et que vous avez gaspillé
comme aucun gouvernement ne l'a fait
vous avez gaspillé toutes les chances
que donnaient la croissance au cours des
années 2000 puisque l'on constate que le
déficit de la sécurité sociale
vous invite accrue à partir de 2003 2004
à une période où de crise il n'était pas
question et donc je crois que il faut
rappeler que l'effort qui est engagé par
ce gouvernement pour le rétablissement
de nos comptes est un effort tout à fait
important et qu'il passe comme la
rappeler monsieur daudini comme l'ont
appelé de nombreuses intervenants sur
les bancs de la majorité que cela passe
par des économies tout à fait
significatives et d'ailleurs monsieur
roche la lui-même reconnu l'ONDAM est
tenue respectée ce qui est le signe
d'une politique
volontariste j'ai entendu
les suggestions les propositions de
Monsieur Dassault et je veux dire que la
priorité la volonté de ce gouvernement
c'est de faire en sorte que nous
puissions rétablir le financement de
notre protection sociale d'une manière
qui en assure précisément la pérennité
parce que nous ne pouvons pas continuer
à financer des besoins sociaux aussi par
ailleurs ces besoins venaient peser de
façon trop lourde sur les entreprises et
sur le coup du travail mais pour autant
nous avons des priorités que nous
affichons et nous ne voulons pas
renoncer à ces engagements qui sont les
nôtres permettez-moi de saluer à nouveau
le travail de Christiane de montais
comme rapporteur sur ou pour la branche
vieillesse et qui prolonge ici le
travail tout à fait
intense qu'elle a accompli à l'occasion
du texte que nous avons examiné sur les
retraites oui madame Pasquet nous avons
une volonté commune je crois qui est de
renforcer de maintenir de moderniser
notre politique familiale et de ce point
de vue là j'ai bien entendu que vous
reconnaissiez que nous prenions en
compte l'évolution des attentes
l'évolution des demandes notamment à
travers la création de place mais nous
avons
résoudre ou à diminuer et puis à
résoudre la question des déficits vous
l'avez vous-même indiqué nous le faisons
en demandant un effort mesuré aux
familles et qui ne vient pas remettre en
question
l'équilibre de cette branche famille
nous avons sans doute un désaccord qui
est de considérer que le financement de
cette branche famille ne pourrait être
assurée ou devrait être assuré de
manière exclusive à partir des revenus
du travail alors que pour nous la
politique familiale est aussi une
politique qui relève de la solidarité
nationale il n'est donc pas anormal de
ce point de vue que le budget de l'État
y contribue et madame la sénatrice
Michel meunier c'est inscrite dans cette
perspective marquant l'engagement du
gouvernement de redresser la branche
famille en faisant appel à une
contribution ou un effort mesuré de la
part des familles les plus aisées alors
plusieurs interventions
ont traité de la question de la branche
ATMP avec des approches d'ailleurs
différentes madame Aïki vous avez
souligné de façon très juste
l'importance de cette branche qu'on a
tendance à sous-estimer d'ailleurs
puisqu'elle est sans doute l'une des
plus petites même si c'est la branche
historique de la sécurité sociale vous
avez marqué que nous nous engageions
dans la voie d'un équilibre dont vous
avez souhaité comme le gouvernement
d'ailleurs qu'il soit durable je veux
vous dire que le rétablissement de
l'équilibre
est lié évidemment à la diminution du
nombre d'accidents du travail et que
cette diminution n'est pas simplement
conjoncturelle et donc nous avons bon
espoir que nous sommes là face à un
phénomène structurel qui nous permet
d'envisager l'avenir de façon positive
monsieur
jean-Pierre Godefroy monsieur le
sénateur vous avez évoqué la question de
la dotation au FIVA monsieur Derio
également je veux vous rappeler
l'engagement qui est le mien que lui du
gouvernement en faveur des victimes de
l'amiante et comme vous l'avez vous-même
remarqué d'ailleurs l'évolution des
dépenses de ce fond résulte avant tout
d'un traitement plus rapide des demandes
ce que j'ai souhaité et ce dont je me
réjouis je comprends votre préoccupation
par rapport à la participation de l'État
je veux dire que que je l'entends et je
peux vous assurer que l'État ne se
dérobera pas à ses responsabilités si il
s'avérait que cette contribution était
nécessaire il ne s'agit donc pas d'un
retrait de la part de l'État mais bien
d'une juste appréciation de l'équilibre
de cette branche pour ce qui est du
médico-social monsieur le rapporteur la
basée vous avez souligné que la
préservation de l'ONDAM médico-social
allait permettre de soutenir ce secteur
vous avez aussi souligné les progrès qui
ont été effectués dans le calendrier de
la campagne tarifaire et je m'en réjouis
et puis vous avez salué les perspectives
ouverte par la future réforme de
l'autonomie qui va permettre des
avancées
fondamentales pour les personnes perdant
leur autonomie pour leurs proches les
aidants et je dois dire que comme vous
je considère que nous n'avons pas
beaucoup de leçons là encore à recevoir
de la part d'une opposition qui
aujourd'hui se veut la première
défenseur de la loi autonomie qui nous a
été annoncé pendant 5 ans sans que
jamais elle ne soit mise en oeuvre et
quand je dis voilà et donc c'est c'était
l'arlésienne du précédent
quinquennat et donc vous avez raison
monsieur lavazzet de marquer que ce
gouvernement lui s'engage et que nous
avons à l'occasion de ce débat la
possibilité de marquer nos premières
priorités priorité qui concerneront
aussi les maladies neurodégénératives
les personnes souffrant de la maladie
d'Alzheimer dont Monsieur kerdra en
souligné toute l'importance qu'il y
avait à les prendre en compte et ses
enjeux je tiens le point de vue là à
vous rassurer monsieur la basée sont
d'ores et déjà parfaitement dans les
contes de la CNSA pour ce qui est de la
politique de santé de la branche
assurance maladie yves Daudigny a marqué
la forte convergence qu'il y a et c'est
normal d'ailleurs entre les propositions
de ce PLFSS et la stratégie nationale de
santé propos qui ont été
disons repris également par Madame
Génisson parce qu'il y a des choix et
des priorités dans ce texte vous pouvez
ne pas partager ces priorités mais ces
priorités elles sont identifiées et
elles sont pour nous ce qui justifie que
nous accordions des financements à
certaines orientations priorité donnée à
la politique de prévention à travers
toute une série de mesures parce que
nous considérons que nous devons faire
en sorte de faire évoluer notre
politique de santé vers une meilleure
prise en compte de la prévention
politique de réorganisation de notre
système de soins en faveur de la
proximité et du premier recours c'est ce
sur quoi ont insisté madame Génisson
monsieur Tropeano en particulier
Monsieur Alain Milon également
d'ailleurs même s'il ne partage pas
forcément les options que nous
présentons mais qui considère que cette
réorganisation est aussi nécessaire je
veux d'ailleurs de ce point de vue
indiqué que il y a une priorité pour
nous qui est celle de l'accès aux soins
de la lutte contre les inégalités madame
Archambault dans le prolongement de son
rapport y est revenu et de ce point de
vue là c'est un des fils conducteurs de
la politique qui est menée et c'est ce
qui justifie des mesures que nous
proposons en ce qui concerne l'accès à
des complémentaires santé et là je
voudrais dire à Dominique wattrain
monsieur le sénateur que nous pouvons
avoir des accords des plus loin à corps
sur certaines mesures de ce texte nous
pouvons avoir des désaccords
fondamentaux par exemple sur l'approche
en termes de financement que vous
présentez mais je vous demande ne pas
ériger des sujets de désaccord qui sont
de faux sujets le désaccord parce que à
aucun moment vous ne pouvez trouver dans
ce texte de quoi nourrir votre discours
sur le fait que nous viendrions
encourager la prise en charge par des
organismes complémentaires au détriment
de l'assurance maladie obligatoire alors
même que toute la politique de ce
gouvernement a précisément pour objet de
renforcer le socle de l'assurance
maladie obligatoire et du réguler les
organismes complémentaires précisément
parce que nous ne voulons pas que ce
soit la porte ouverte au à une prise en
charge par ces organismes
complémentaires je veux
j'ai entendu diverses interventions sur
le financement des hôpitaux franchement
monsieur Larcher monsieur le sénateur
au cours des années passées il y a eu un
investissement inconsidéré un
investissement hospitalier inconsidéré
qui a abouti à renforcer ou à augmenter
et vous le savez fort bien la dette des
établissements hospitaliers parce que le
tout ça n'est pas de dire on veut de
l'investissement encore faut-il que
l'investissement se traduisent par une
charge soutenable pour les
établissements hospitaliers je ne dirai
rien des monceaux d'engagement pris par
le précédent gouvernement en faveur
d'investissement qui n'ont jamais vu un
kopeck de financement et pour ne pas
parler d'un kopeck parce qu'on pourrait
se dire que au fond ça n'est pas très
disons aux engageants très engageants
pas un euro de financement n'était prévu
nous avons donc mis en place une
politique qui permet de déterminer les
priorités en matière d'investissement
hospitalier priorité qui est le sont
financer il ne s'agit pas d'une démarche
technocratique il s'agit tout simplement
de garantir que lorsque l'on annonce un
investissement hospitalier cet
investissement verra toujours parce
qu'au fond pour nos concitoyens ce qui
compte ça n'est pas que l'on grandisse
des lettres en disant le ministre ou la
ministre m'a dit que j'allais avoir de
l'argent pour mon hôpital ce qui compte
pour nos concitoyens c'est que très
concrètement leurs établissements
hospitaliers s'améliorent et répondre à
leurs besoins au quotidien et de ce
point de vue c'est c'est aussi pour cela
que nous engageons la réforme de la
tarification qui madame Cohen n'a pas
pour objectif évidemment pas pour effet
selon nous de fragiliser l'hôpital
public qui a au contraire pour objectif
de conforter l'hôpital dans ses missions
en permettant de mieux identifier les
besoins de financement de chacun et de
répondre aux situations particulières de
certains établissements par exemple les
établissements isolés je
dirait un mot également des propos qui
ont été tenus sur la politique du
médicament en particulier par Monsieur
Barbier même si nous avons eu l'occasion
je l'ai rappelé tout à l'heure à la
tribune d'avoir un long échange sur
cette question il y a quelques semaines
à votre initiative d'ailleurs les
mesures qui sont présentées dans ce
texte n'ont absolument pas pour objet de
compromettre l'innovation elles ont pour
objet de garantir un juste financement
et je le dis à Monsieur Charron
également de garantir un juste
financement des médicaments de
concentrer l'investissement dans
l'innovation dans les secteurs qui le
requiert mais de permettre une bonne
régulation de la politique du médicament
par ailleurs je veux remercier Monsieur
Tropeano du soutien qu'il apporte à la
politique en matière de santé publique
en direction du sevrage tabagique vous
avez souhaité monsieur le sénateur que
nous puissions aller plus loin je peux
le comprendre et je crois que nous
devons en tout cas à partir de ces
mesures là faire des expérimentations et
voir comment nous pourrons poursuivre ce
travail et je terminerai d'un mot
en disant
que la question au fond je ne rentrerai
même pas dans le débat de fond mais
madame Rossignol a évoqué cette question
fondamentale du droit à l'IVG c'est un
droit
moi je ne crois pas que ce droit doit
être banalisés aucun droit ne peut être
banalisé mais je veux dire très
fermement que ce droit est là il existe
que ce droit il doit être défendu par
tous dans notre pays et j'espère que on
n'a pas à rendre compte de sa vie privée
et de ses choix personnels pour avoir la
possibilité de défendre à la tribune de
cette assemblée le droit à l'IVG
j'espère tout simplement mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qu'il y a dans
cette hémicycle des hommes pour défendre
le droit à l'IVG et que on ne demande
pas à quelqu'un qui vient dire qu'il
s'agit de garantir concrètement au
quotidien l'effectivité de ce droit
qu'on ne vient pas lui demander pour
preuve de sa sincérité du nombre de fois
où elle est allée demander à pouvoir
bénéficier personnellement de ce droit
c'est là franchement la mise en cause de
la démocratie et de la manière dont nous
concevons ce débat nous devons ici dans
le cadre de ce texte il y a des mesures
qui ne concernent pas l'IVG qui concerne
l'accès à la contraception l'année
dernière il y avait des mesures sur
l'IVG dans le PLFSS qui est devenu LFSS
et qui ont permis notamment
l'augmentation des tarifs pour la
réalisation de ces actes mais ce sont là
des droits auxquels nous devons ensemble
veiller et dont nous devons ensemble
veiller à l'effectivité
merci madame la ministre
la discussion générale éclose et nous
passons à la discussion des articles
nous abordons les dispositions de la
première partie du projet de loi
relative à l'exercice 2012 j'ai une
demande de parole monsieur Barbier
oui monsieur le Président et Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues je ne
voudrais pas qu'elle méprise sur cette
affaire je n'ai pas interrogé madame
Rossignol sur le savoir si elle avait
recours j'ai dit simplement que quand on
a une IVG il faut savoir de quoi on
parle moi j'ai un petit avantage dans
cette affaire c'est que je n'étais pas
député en 74 mais en 79 j'ai voté la loi
je pense que Madame Weil a été d'une
femme courageuse qui a assumé et il y a
un certain nombre de choses
qui sont importantes j'ai aussi et vous
savez c'était pas facile à l'époque j'ai
installé dans mon dans mon hôpital de
Dole j'ai pratiqué plus de 300 IVG alors
qu'on était au banc de la société encore
un petit peu comme ça j'étais dans la
majorité de l'époque j'ai pratiqué c'est
ça que je voulais vous dire Madame et
simplement quand vous mettez en rôle en
jeu le délai de jours c'est qu'on
n'avait pas la pratique de cet examen il
est pas possible de pratiquer une IVG
chirurgicale sans avoir un minimum
d'examen savoir si cette personne a ses
antécédents de connaître on les
pratiquait je pense que c'est toujours
comme ça sous anesthésie générale il
faut une consultation
d'anesthésie générale vous pouvez pas
faire ça dans la foulée ça ne se fait
pas dans les hôpitaux en tout cas c'est
pas comme ça que ça se pratique ça se
pratique comme ça sur les coins de table
à l'époque madame veille a eu le courage
de faire ça et je pense que si vous
pouvez considérer que cette chose doit
être révisée je crois qu'il faut bien
réfléchir aux problèmes non seulement
éthiques mais au problème pratique de la
pratique de l'IVG et c'est pas facile je
peux vous dire par expérience contre
beaucoup de gens de mon opinion que
c'est pas facile à pratiquer quand vous
êtes médecin
je vous en prie
de réflexion qui est un délai qui n'est
quasiment que spécifique à l'IVG
alors nous arrivons à l'article premier
j'ai une demande de parole de Monsieur
Alain Milo
merci monsieur le Président en fait ma
prise de parole se fera sur la partie
1er l'article 2
comme à chaque pdfss conformément à la
loi organique du 2 août 2005 nous
examinons évidemment les comptes du
dernier exercice clos pour 2012 donc le
régime général affiche un déficit gombal
de 13,3 milliards d'euros en diminution
de 4,1 milliard par rapport à l'exercice
précédent qui était de 17,4 en 2011 la
réduction du déficit ainsi opéré entre
les années 2011 et les années 2012 et
surtout visible dans la branche maladie
où il est passé de 8,6 à 5 9 milliards
d'euros
ce résultat est à mettre au crédit des
efforts considérables assumer aussi bien
sur le volet de la médecine ambulatoire
que sur celui du médicament en outre
nous constatons que l'on dame a été
respecté ces trois dernières années
grâce aussi à l'action de la précédente
majorité les derniers efforts sont à
signaler mais n'oublions pas le rôle de
notre majorité dans la réduction de ce
déficit qui avait réussi à inciter
l'ensemble du corps médical à respecter
l'ONDAM nous devons aujourd'hui saluer
leur responsabilité nous devons donc
faire encore plus d'efforts évidemment
afin de maîtriser nos concessions et de
réduire ce déficit qui reste l'un des
plus élevés d'Europe mais cet exercice
2012 retrace aussi les mesures prises
par la nouvelle majorité notamment en
loi de finances rectificative je pense à
la hausse de 0,2 points du taux de
cotisation vieillesse qui pèse 150
millions d'euros sur les deux derniers
mois de 2012 à la hausse de 8 à 20% du
taux du forfait social sur la branche vs
et le FSV à la suppression de
l'exonération des heures supplémentaires
et complémentaires nous ne soutenons pas
cette politique qui consiste à alourdir
le coude du travail et à augmenter les
prélèvements tous azimuts nous nous
abstiendrons donc sur les articles 1 et
2 de la première partie de ce belfs
merci chers collègues je demande de voir
paroles Monsieur Roland Courtot
merci monsieur le Président si depuis
2012 nous avons cherché endiguer les
dérives qui menaçaient le fonctionnement
de notre protection sociale j'apprécie
que désormais nous puissions nous
engager dans des réformes structurelles
qui poursuivront sans redressement
moderniser ce système qui nous est si
cher à assurer sa pérennité sans léser
le périmètre de la protection sociale
voilà la seule voie qui à notre avis
vaillent au cours de ces 18 derniers
mois avec le gouvernement ont été
prise les mesures nécessaires à
l'inversion et à la diminution des
déficit sociaux malgré la crise et son
impact sur la conjoncture économique je
voulais vous féliciter madame la
ministre de poursuivre dans cette voie
et de mener un travail responsable en
effet la responsabilité
ça n'est pas forcément de faire ce qui
est populaire mais de faire ce qui est
juste pour l'intérêt général bref les
résultats sont notables plus
remarquables qu'ils interviennent dans
un contexte je le redis économique
difficile force de constater que ces
mesures juste nécessaire n'avaient pas
été prise à l'époque nous déplorons
parce que nous en subissons aujourd'hui
les conséquences mais nous ne fierons
pas nos responsabilités et nous
assumerons pleinement cette tâche qui
nous incombe désormais c'est pourquoi
grâce à l'ensemble des réformes engagées
à l'horizon 2017
je vous renvoie ce profilé une
trajectoire crédible de retour à
l'équilibre des comptes sociaux il est
évident que cette bataille n'est pas
aisée elle nécessite du courage et des
efforts mais elle a en vaut la peine ce
qui se joue ici c'est une sauvetage de
notre modèle social un modèle fondateur
de notre pacte républicain aussi
bénéficiant des effets financiers des
mesures structurelles que vous avez
mises en place jusqu'à présent madame la
ministre le déficit de l'ensemble des
régimes de base et du FSV est fixé à
13,2 milliards d'euros pour 2014 et
celui du régime général repasserait sous
la barre des 10 milliards pour avoisiner
le seuil de 9,6 milliards et ainsi
revenir au niveau que nous avions connu
avant la crise ce qui plus encourageant
justifie et légitime la politique que
vous conduisez et que nous soutenons les
réformes engagées jusqu'à présent par ce
gouvernement vont permettre d'adapter
notre système à la réalité de la société
nous ne pouvons plus nous permettre
d'attendre nous ne pouvons plus laisser
filer les déficit en espérant qu'un jour
les choses s'arrangeront d'elles-mêmes
non il faut agir il faut du courage de
la volonté vous en avez madame la
ministre et nous vous soutiendrons dans
cette entreprise Les Contes de la
branche vieillesse se redressent parce
que des mesures ont été prises en ce
sens le déficit passe de 4,8 milliards
d'euros en 2012 à 3,3 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui et ça n'est pas par magie
mais grâce aux mesures adopter l'an
dernier sur la hausse du forfait social
et des prélèvements sur les revenus du
capital en 2014 le déficit continuera se
résorber pour atteindre 1,3 milliards
d'euros grâce aux mesures proposées dans
la réforme enfin l'augmentation
nécessaire bien modérée de la durée de
cotisation après 2000 permettra à la
branche de retrouver l'équilibre à long
et désormais cet équilibre sera assuré
en cas de variation conjoncturelle grâce
au recours au fond de réserve des
retraites qui retrouvent ainsi sa
vocation originelle c'est-à-dire
soutenir les régimes après 2020 nous ne
stigmatisons personne et l'effort
devrait être partagé jeune plus âgé
employés employeur entreprise car la
protection sociale et les retraites sont
l'affaire de toujours merci c'est chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Dominique va-train
l'exercice de l'examen par le Sénat des
premiers articles des projets de loi de
finances de financement de la sécurité
sociale et des plus intéressants ces
articles concernent traditionnellement
les dispositions relatives aux exercices
précédents et il est pour chacun d'entre
nous l'occasion de mesurer les effets
réels des lois de financement qui ont
été adoptées ainsi cet article 1 nous
propose d'approuver les tableaux
d'équilibre par branche du dernier
exercice clos des régimes obligatoires
de base de la sécurité sociale nous
prenons acte du fait qu'en 2012 le
déficit du régime général à
effectivement baisser puisqu'il a
diminué de 4 milliards d'euros par
rapport à 2011 pour autant les déficits
restent importants et continuent à
hypothéquer l'avenir de notre protection
sociale nous sommes donc tout comme vous
sensible à la résorption des déficits
sociaux pour autant
nous ne pouvons pas souscrire aux
orientations de la droite mise en oeuvre
dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2012 puisque la
réduction des déficits s'est opéré quasi
exclusivement sur le compte des assurés
d'ailleurs force est de constater que
ces solutions sont mauvaises puisque
même si les déficits baisse passant de
25 milliards en 2010 à 19 en 2011 puis
15 en 2012 le rythme de résorption du
déficit décélère d'année en année nous y
voyons pour notre part la démonstration
de ce que nous ne cessons de rappeler
depuis plusieurs années les mesures
adoptées de réduction des dépenses sont
des mesures insuffisantes et surtout
inefficace pour remuer durablement avec
l'équilibre et certaines d'entre elles
sont tout simplement injustes je pense
par exemple aux franchises médicales qui
s'appliquent à toutes et tous notamment
victimes des accidents du travail et des
maladies professionnel de la même
manière nous ne pouvons que regretter la
réduction du déficit de la branche
vieillesse ramenée de 6 milliards
d'euros en 2011 à 4,8 milliards d'euros
en 2012 qui n'est que le fruit de
mesures injustes imposé aux salariés par
la réforme word Sarkozy tel que le
report de l'âge de départ la retraite le
report de la date de revalorisation des
pensions enfin je veux dire mon
inquiétude quant à la situation du fond
de solidarité vieillesse déficitaire
depuis 2009 il a connu en 2012 une
aggravation notable de son déficit
environ 4 milliards d'euros contre 3,4
en 2011 cette accroissement des déficits
résulte notamment et principalement de
l'augmentation de la prise en charge du
minimum contributif qu'il finance
puisque son coût est passé de 3,5
milliards d'euros en 2011 à 3,9
milliards en 2012 tout cela traduit
l'explosion inégalité sociale ainsi que
la stagnation des salaires et des
pensions ainsi également que l'explosion
du nombre de travailleurs pauvres les
conséquences de ces mesures nous les
mesurons à l'aune du nombre de retraités
qui au final ne dispose plus pour
survivre que du minimum contributif face
à un tel constat nous appelons des
réformes courageuses en manière en
matière de répartition des richesses et
bien sûr nous ne voterons pas ces
articles 1 et 2 merci cher collègue
alors nous allons voter sur l'article
premier je n'ai pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet article veuillent
bien lever la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre et bien
lever la main
abstention
il est à adopté sur l'article 2 j'ai une
demande de parole de madame Isabelle
Pasquet
merci monsieur le Président à l'occasion
de cet article 2
je voudrais faire part de mon inquiétude
sur une situation que je qualifierai
d'anomalie en effet l'annexe au projet
de loi nous permet de prendre conscience
qu'une partie du déficit du régime
général de 2011 n'a pas été transféré à
la CADES il faut dire que pour se faire
le gouvernement aurait dû en application
de la loi organique prendre soit la
décision de prolonger de la durée de vie
de la Cadès et donc repousser la date à
partir de laquelle est difficile devrait
être résorbé soit transférer à la CADES
une source supplémentaire de financement
c'est donc la cause qui a été contrainte
de supporter une partie de cette dette
conduisant à porter son plafond d'un
point à 22 milliards d'euros pour
l'exercice 2012 mais ce n'est pas le
rôle de la cosse puisque puisqu'elle est
théoriquement chargée que des
financements à court terme aussi madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous préciser les
conditions dans lesquelles cette
opération de financement de la dette à
moyen terme a été menée et je précise la
question les taux qui ont été appliqués
à la cosse par rapport à ceux de ces
financements à court terme en fait je
voudrais également dire quelques mots
sur la situation de la branche retraite
des exploitants agricoles celles-ci est
structurellement déficitaire et personne
ne semble se soucier réellement des
causes de ce difficile en 2012 il
s'établit un milliard d'euros
contraignant la mutualité sociale
agricole
à financer ses besoins de trésorerie
dans la limite de 2 milliards 9 alors si
la branche retrait des exploitants
agricoles et dans une telle situation
c'est en raison de l'assiette de
cotisation appliquée pour mémoire les
exploitants agricoles peuvent déduire de
cette assiette les investissements
qu'ils réalisent si nous comprenons la
volonté des législateurs de favoriser
l'investissement agricole nous ne
pouvons nous ne pouvons pas admettre que
cela se fasse au détriment de la
protection sociale obligatoire de base
cela doit relever d'une politique
fiscale qui mérite sans doute des
adaptations mais certainement pas d'une
dérogation principe de financement de la
Sécurité Sociale Agricole je remercie
merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes de parole sur
l'article 2
votons sur l'article 2 que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet article va bien
lever la main
merci
avis contraire
abstention
l'article est adopté je vais mettre voix
l'ensemble de la première partie du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 y a-t-il des
demandes d'explication de vote je mets
donc au volant l'ensemble de la première
partie que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter
veuille bien lever la main
merci à vie contraire
abstention
est adoptée nous abordons les
dispositions de la deuxième partie
relative à l'exercice 2013 sur l'article
3 j'ai une demande de parole de Monsieur
à la maison
oui monsieur le Président Madame et
ministre merci cet article 3 prévoit de
transférer 90 80% pardon des excédents
du fond pour l'emploi hospitalier vers
la Caisse nationale de retraite des
agents des collectivités territoriales
dans l'étude d'impact le gouvernement
indique que la CNRACL devra à nouveau
recourir dans la limite du plafond
d'emprunt fixé par le PLFSS pour 2014 à
des financements pour assurer ses
besoins de trésorerie en 2014 qui
atteindront jusqu'à 800 millions d'euros
en février pour minorer le montant des
emprunts que devra contacter la Caisse
des Dépôts gestionnaires du régime le
gouvernement propose d'utiliser une
partie des excédents de la FEH
après l'augmentation des cotisations
employeur des hôpitaux et des
collectivités locales pour rééquilibrer
les comptes de leur caisse de retraite
qui a pénalisé les budgets déjà sous
tension vous proposez de détourner les
ressources du FEH pour enflourer la
cnrcl je rappelle qu'à l'hôpital les
déficits ne sont toujours pas résorbés
notamment dans les plus gros
établissements selon les chiffres
consolidés et définitifs de la FHF les
hôpitaux publics français ont affiché un
déficit de 150 millions d'euros en 2012
le fond pour l'emploi hospitalier a été
créé par la loi du 25 juillet 94
relative à l'organisation du temps de
travail au recrutement et aux mutations
dans la fonction publique pour financer
certains indemnités allouées aux agents
des hôpitaux
il contribue au financement des droits à
congés acquis au titre de la réduction
du temps de travail il est alimenté par
une contribution à la charge des
établissements soit 1% de la masse
salariale des hospitaliers publics ce
qui est substantiel aujourd'hui le
gouvernement entend dépouillé le FH pour
financer la scène Racl qui souffre de
problèmes chroniques de trésorerie et
qui a été plusieurs fois par le passé
mise à contribution elle-même une
ponction de 200 millions est donc
envisagée et ce alors qu'il existe des
besoins dans les hôpitaux le FEH
finançant comme je l'ai déjà évoqué les
recrutements et les mutations dans les
services hospitaliers je m'éloigne du
sujet de cet article 3 quelques instants
s'agissant des ressources humaines dans
les hôpitaux il aurait été selon nous
plus sage d'épargner à l'hôpital la
remise en cause du jour de carence et de
cons acrer les sommes économisées au bas
salaire et aux évolutions de carrière
nous ne sommes donc pas du tout
favorables à cet article merci cher
collègue nous en arrivons à l'amendement
144 il est présenté par Monsieur roche
oui l'objet de cette amendement et de
supprimer cet article qui effectue une
ponction justifiée du fond pour l'emploi
hospitalier le FEH qui finance
l'aménagement du temps de travail des
personnels hospitaliers au profit de la
caisse nationale de retraite des agences
de collectivités locales la CNRACL qui
assure le risque vieillis le FH est
alimenté par une contribution de 1% de
la masse salariale à la charge des
employeurs hospitaliers pour prendre en
charge des surcos titre du temps partiel
de la cessation d'anticiper d'activité
du compte éparpin et des 35 heures rien
donc avoir avec la retraite il s'agit
des mesures purement comptables le FH
dispose de 233 millions d'euros de
réserve le
CNRAC l'année prochaine un besoin
trésorerie de 800 millions il s'agit
d'un petit hold-up au détriment de
l'aménagement du temps de travail du
personnel nous pensons pas que ce type
de mesure et de nature assuré la
pérennité encore moins l'équité du
système de retraite et nous demandons
donc sans retrait si chers collègues sur
rapporteur quelle est la ville de la
Commission
ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues comme indiqué donc c'est
un rendement demande la suppression de
l'article 3 prévoyant un transfert de
200 millions d'euros des réserves du FEH
vers les comptes de la CNRS cet article
propose pourtant une mesure de bonne
gestion des comptes sociaux elle
transfert c'est cette mesure 200
millions d'un fonds structurellement
avec sédentaire plus de 35 millions
d'euros par an au cours des quatre
dernières années vers une caisse de
retraite structurellement déficitaire
elle effectue par ailleurs ce transfert
entre deux entités ayant les mêmes
bénéficiaires à savoir les personnels
des collectivités locales et des
établissements hospitaliers pour mémoire
le fond pour l'emploi hospitalier
finance en effet non seulement les
surcoûts financiers liées au temps
partiel ou formation et aux comptes
épargne tant des personnels hospitaliers
mais aussi se lier à la cessation
possible d'activité des agents
titulaires des collectivités locales la
commission a donné un avis défavorable à
cet amendement
général madame la ministre ou monsieur
le ministre la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
bien monsieur sanator c'est le même avis
que le rapporteur il ne s'agit pas
contrairement à l'expression qui a été
utilisée d'un hold-up mais d'un
remontage
je veux
sur ce sujet
donner
toutes les explications ce transfert de
200 millions d'euros du FEH au profit de
la CNRACL permet de garantir un fonds de
roulement suffisant pour le FEH tout en
réduisant le déficit prévisionnel de la
caisse à 220 millions d'euros là où il
aurait été de 420 millions d'euros si
nous n'avions rien fait le gouvernement
vous le savez adopter des mesures
extrêmement fortes de redressement du
régime des mesures exceptionnel
d'affectation de réserve d'autres fonds
mais également des mesures pérennes avec
le relèvement de la contribution
employeur de 1,45 en 2013 et 1-35 en
2014 les mesures arrêtées dans le cadre
du projet de loi sur les retraites
décalages de la date de valorisation de
revalorisation hausse des cotisations
des agents et des employeurs
contribueront également à améliorer la
situation de la CNRACL les déficits de
la slrcl la contraigne à recourir les
financements extérieurs pour faire face
à des besoins de trésorerie qui restent
importants à chaque fin de mois
notamment du fait du décalage entre la
date de versement des pensions servis
trois jours avant la fin du mois la date
de recouvrement des cotisations le 5 du
mois suivant c'est la raison pour
laquelle il a été prévu un transfert
exceptionnel de 200 millions d'euros du
font pour l'emploi hospitalier qui
permettra d'alléger les besoins de
trésorerie auquel la caisse devra faire
face
en fin d'année si mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ont adoptaient pas cette
mesure de redoutage
cela aurait des conséquences tout à fait
néfastes en matière de déficit de la
cnrsl ce qui vous contrarirait
grandement ce que ce qui pourrait même
vous faire de la peine c'est la raison
pour laquelle je ne peux pas donner un
avis favorable à cet amendement
merci monsieur le ministre pour
explication de vote monsieur de Mezel
merci monsieur le président madame et
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord la CNRS
déficit structurel tout simplement parce
que depuis
74 on prélève des sons importantes 64 65
milliards ont été prélevés depuis cette
date sur cette caisse qui est la caisse
des agents des collectivités locales qui
regroupent à la fois les fonctionnaires
territoriaux les fonctionnaires
hospitaliers
le en 2013 en 2013
nous nous sommes aperçus les uns et les
autres qu'il y avait un fond qui était
le fond de compensation de la sensation
progressive d'activité qui avait des
réserves de 400 millions qui ne
servaient à rien et qui avait été
financé par un sur la même base que la
celle de la cotisation à la céléraciale
c'est la raison pour laquelle se font
qui ne vient plus aucune utilité a été
complètement vidée et comme il
s'agissait du même périmètre et du même
s'adressant aux mêmes collectivités et
bien tout ça a été transféré à la
génération même s'il n'y a pas de
lien direct entre le Fonds de
compensation de cessation progressive
d'activité et la caisse de retraite
une opération
identique a été faite pour le fond de la
location temporaire
d'invalidité des collectivités locales
et là également il y a moins de il y a
une excédent c'est excédent a été
partiellement
transférés à l'incinération et
parallèlement le taux de l'allocation
temporaire d'invalidité a été diminué
pour les collectivités locales et par
voie de conséquences le taux de la
scénératiel a été augmentée ce qui est
une opération blanche pour les
collectivités locales
mais le problème c'est que il y avait
ça a créé une différence entre le
traitement pour les hospitaliers et les
collectivités locales
car ce que je viens de dire ne concerner
que les collectivités locales donc il
fallait rétablir et faire avoir une
situation
identique pour les Hospitaliers
et comme le fond de compensation de
cessation progressive d'activité
n'existe pas pour les Hospitaliers mais
qu'il était supporté par le fond le FH
c'est sur ce fond qui est un peu le
parallèle du fond dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure pour les collectivités locales
et il était il est tout à fait normal
par parallélisme qu'on traite les
Hospitaliers comme on l'a fait pour les
collectivités locales et tout ça est
tout à fait normal et bien évidemment
si c'est 200 millions
n'étaient pas transférés l'accélération
ne bénéficierait pas de décès de 130 de
ces 200 millions et
devrait pourquoi pas
éventuellement augmenter ses taux
pour compenser or il serait tout de même
anormal qu'il faille augmenter le taux
des collectivités locales sous le
prétexte qu'il n'y a pas une attitude
identique pour les Hospitaliers
concernant la cessation progressive
d'activité c'est la raison pour laquelle
pour ceux qui me concernent bien
évidemment je pense qu'il faut maintenir
cet article 3
avec peut-être un aménagement tel qu'il
a été proposé par la Commission donc je
pense qu'il faut être contre je pense je
suis vraiment persuadé qu'il faut être
contre la suppression de cet article
merci merci cher collègue la parole de
Madame Cohen pour expiration de vote
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le
ministre
précieux de raison
la première c'est que s'il existe
effectivement un déficit de la Caisse
nationale de retraite des agents des
collectivités
locales c'est en partie du fait de la
façon dont vous avez géré les affaires
par le passé à droite du fait de
l'application de la RGPP et de la case
de l'emploi public et ça c'est pas
récent hélas la deuxième raison c'est
parce que nous pensons qu'il est tout à
fait possible et envisageable de
d'élaborer une autre une autre écriture
de cet article avec un financement
alternatif
au prélèvement opéré sur le FH et ça
sera l'objet de notre amendement 159
donc pour ces deux raisons qui nous
paraissent importantes nous voterons
contre l'amendement de suppression merci
chers collègues monsieur Alami à la
parole pour expiration monsieur le
Président Monsieur ministre je je vous
remercie d'avoir rectifié le tir c'est
vrai que le terme de hold-up était un
petit peu fort et que le terme de
regroupage qui veut dire la même chose
mais dans un langage postal est meilleur
dans ces conditions j'accepte ce
terme-là mais je voterai les nouveaux
tronc quand même pour l'amendement de
Monsieur roche merci cher collègue je
n'ai pas d'autres demandes d'explication
de votre site monsieur
le Président j'ai j'ai l'impression de
vivre une situation déjà connue
celle de notre discussion du PLFSS de
l'an dernier le premier PLFSS du
gouvernement je me souviens à l'époque
que le gouvernement avait pris des
dispositions et notamment en passant par
des augmentations de cotisations
sociales pour équilibrer des régimes de
traite qui se retrouvaient
particulièrement déficitaire je pense à
la Caisse nationale de
des collectivités locales je pense au
régime social de des indépendants qui
étaient des régimes qui risquaient de se
retrouver en cessation de paiement
c'est-à-dire dans l'incapacité à la fin
de l'année 2013 de payer des pensions
et nous avions eu un grand débat et je
me souviens de la peau de la position
des groupes de l'opposition c'est
notoriale qui était de dire non non il
ne faut pas équilibrer ces régimes quel
que soit la mesure que prenne le
gouvernement nous sommes exactement dans
la même situation un an après nous avons
un régime celui des collectivités
locales qui est
structurellement déficitaire notamment à
raison du rapport démographique qui est
particulièrement défavorable et en
particulier dans le centre oui monsieur
domezel le rapport démographique de la
CNRACL et particulièrement défavorable
et nous avons par ailleurs les les
séquelles de la décentralisation de 2004
et que nous dit l'opposition c'est
l'inciennatoriale bah non il faut pas
équilibrer sur le régime alors même que
le gouvernement a été obligé d'augmenter
la cotisation sociale le ministre du
Budget l'a rappelé à l'instant pour 2013
1,35% pour 2014 1,45%
du coup faut-il aller
vous proposez peut-être d'augmenter un
nouveau des cotisations employeur
donc il me semble que c'est de bonne
politique à un moment donné de mobiliser
une trésorerie qui dort qui ne s'est
rigoureusement à rien pour pouvoir
contribuer à équilibrer un régime qui
sent cette mesure risquerait de se
retrouver dans la situation où au cours
de l'année 2014 elle ne pourrait pas
verser ses pensions de retraite et ses
prestations voilà c'est le même débat
que nous avons l'an dernier c'est la
raison pour laquelle très très
franchement je crois que nous devons
repousser cet amendement de suppression
de l'article 3 ainsi chers collègues je
n'ai pas d'autres demandes d'explication
de vote j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe udic sur
l'amendement 144 je vous rappelle que la
vie de la commission est défavorable la
vie du Gouvernement est défavorable il
va être procédé au scrutin public dans
les conditions fixées l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires à procéder au dépouillement
du scrutin
date du scrutin numéro 45 sur
l'amendement 144 noms de votants 348
noms de suffrages exprimés 348 pour
l'adoption 162 contre 166 le Sénat n'a
pas adopté
deux amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune l'amendement 159 est
présentée par un homme Cohen
et monsieur le Président comme je l'ai
dit donc nous avons un amendement de
réécriture l'article 3 prévoit d'opérer
une ponction de 200 millions d'euros sur
le fond pour l'emploi hospitalier au
profit de la caisse nationale de
retraite des agents des collectivités
locales prélèvement que le gouvernement
jupportun ça a été redit au double motif
que le fond sur lequel il se perd sur
excédentaire et parce que les
établissements publics sont
contributeurs de la même manière qu'il
contribue au financement de la
CNRACL nous contestons cette analyse et
considérant que cette posture n'est pas
juste et plutôt inefficace tout d'abord
la mission du FEH n'est pas de financer
la caisse la
CNRACL ces missions sont pourtant
importantes puisqu'il peut financer des
indemnités exceptionnelles de mobilité
accordée aux fonctionnaires ou
contractuels concernés par une opération
de restructuration entraînant un
changement de travail ou encore pour ne
prendre que cet exemple financer les
congés de formation professionnelle des
agents de la catégorie c'est l'émission
importantes vous en conviendrez or si ce
fond est excédentaire ils nous sont plus
opportuns de revoir les conditions dans
lesquelles ces crédits peuvent être
opérés plutôt que de le ponctionner ou
bien il faut revoir les conditions dans
lesquelles les établissements de santé
contribuent à abonder un fond qui n'a
pas d'utilité compte tenu de la
situation des hôpitaux le débat vous en
conviendrez mérite d'être engagé par
ailleurs la CNR à Cl n'est pas
structurellement déficitaire elle serait
même excédentaire si elle ne contribuait
pas à financer d'autres régimes de
retraite pour le coup eux
structurellement déficitaire tels que
celui des non salariés agricoles celles
et ceux qui ne cessent de stigmatiser
les fonctionnaires et prône une
harmonisation par le bas en sont pour
leurs frais enfin et c'est le sens de
notre amendement le financement de la
CNR Racl doit reposer comme les
cotisations
sociales dans le secteur privé sur la
masse salariale laquelle la Process de
se réduire en raison des politiques de
destruction d'emplois publics menées
depuis de nombreuses années afin de
mettre un terme à cette situation et
rendre ainsi
inutile la ponction que vous prévoyez
dans cet article nous proposons de
substituer l'actuel article 3 par une
rédaction alternative prévoyant de
majorer la contribution des employeurs
publics qui ne respectent pas
l'obligation de titularisation et
favorise par conséquent le recrutement
de contractuel là où l'embauche de
titulaire serait possible et souhaitable
merci cher collègue l'amendement 62 est
présenté par monsieur le rapporteur
général au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales
ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues il s'agit d'un
amendement de simplification
rédactionnelle le montant du prélèvement
effectué sur les réserves du FEH étant
exprimé en euros et non pourcentage il
est inutile de préciser la date à
laquelle les réserves ont été constatées
merci est-ce que je peux par ailleurs
vous demander l'avis sur l'amendement
159 sur la porteur général
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues afin de résorber le
déficit de la CNRACL c'est un moment
propose donc de remplacer le transfert
proposé par l'article 3 par une hausse
de la contribution des employeurs
publics collectivités locales et
hôpitaux ne respectant pas le processus
de circularisation prévu dans la loi
sauvadée du 12 mars 2012 cette loi du 12
mars 2012 largement enrichi par les
travaux du Sénat et en particulier par
les dispositions introduites à
l'initiative de leur apporteur de la
commission des lois Madame Catherine
taska est en cours de mise en œuvre dans
les différentes fonctions publiques il
me semble donc pas opportun de prévoir
de sanctions pour l'application d'un
texte qui va dans le bon sens et que les
administrations centrales les
collectivités locales et les hôpitaux
sont en train de s'approprier je propose
aux dépositaires de l'amendement de
rediscuter de la mise en place d'une
telle mesure à l'issue de la période de
4 ans fixée par l'accord du 31 mars 2011
pour la mise en oeuvre du 15e plan de
résorption de la précarité dans les
administrations de l'État des
collectivités locales et des
établissements sociaux et de santé sur
ces éléments la commission a donné un
avis défavorable à l'amendement merci
monsieur le rapporteur général madame la
ministre ou monsieur le ministre la vie
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
bien monsieur le Président sur le
l'abonnement du rapporteur le
Gouvernement est favorable pour ceux qui
concerne l'amendement 159
gouvernement et défavorable pour les
mêmes raisons que celle que a évoqué le
rapporteur à l'instant la mise en place
d'une majoration de cotisations
vieillesse à la charge des employeurs
qui n'auraient pas mis en oeuvre le
processus de titularisation prévue par
la loi du 12 mars 2012 ne peut être
retenu car cela reviendrait à instaurer
un dispositif de sanctions étrangers à
l'objet de la cotisation vieillesse
elle-même en outre ce dispositif ne
concernerait que les seuls employeurs de
la fonction publique territoriale et
hospitalière et Palaiseau une telle
mesure s'impose d'autant moins que le
gouvernement sera comme vous le savez
très attentif très vigilant à ce que les
établissements de santé les
collectivités territoriales s'acquittent
leur obligation de mise en place d'un
programme d'accès à l'emploi titulaire
et développe une politique active de
titularisation pour cette raison nous ne
sommes pas favorables à cet amendement
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors nous
sommes sur le 159 pattes de demandes
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter va bien lever la main
merci avis contraire
abstention l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 62 pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter va bien lever la
main le 62
merci avis contraire
abstention il est adopté nouveau ton sur
l'article 3 pas de demande d'explication
de vote que ceux qui souhaitent adopter
cet article va bien lever la main
merci avis contraire
abstention
l'article est adopté
nous en arrivant l'article 4 et j'ai une
demande de parole de Monsieur Alain
Milon non en explication de vote alors
trois amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement 156 est présenté par
Monsieur roche
identiques
l'objet de cet amendement est de
supprimer l'article 4 qui incite une
taxation sur les complémentaires qui
méconnaient fondamentalement le sens de
l'engagement pris par une OCAM au moment
de la signature de l'avenant 8 de sa
convention en effet stavenant à la
Convention nationale organise les
rapports entre les médecins libéraux et
l'assurance maladie il prévoit qu'une
cam participe au développement des
nouveaux modes de rémunération en
complétant à hauteur 150 millions
d'euros le financement mis en place par
l'assurance maladie obligatoire mais les
modalités de financement du dispositif
révélatique carte du PLFSS les natures
les engagements pris le dispositif
d'article 4 s'apparente à un prélèvement
global effectué sur les organismes
complémentaires au bénéfice la CNAM il
s'agit en effet d'une taxe et non d'un
financement d'une prestation de soins
cette accession méconnait donc
fondamentalement le sens de l'engagement
pris par une cam au moment de la
signature de la nanoïde c'est pourquoi
nous en demandons la suppression
merci chers collègues l'abonnement 160
et présenté par Monsieur waterin
oui cet article 4 projets d'accroître la
participation des organismes de
protection complémentaire au financement
du forfait médecin traitant cette mesure
est présentée comme la suite de la
signature de l'avenant numéro 8 à la
Convention nationale organisant les
rapports entre les médecins libéraux et
l'assurance maladie avenant signé le 26
juillet 2011 comme vous le savez nous
sommes plus que réservés sur cette
avenant qui légalisent en réalité les
dépassements de nos rêves et pourrait
même inciter les médecins de secteur 1
pratiqués des dépassements puisque
ceux-ci sont en quelque sorte pris en
charge par les organismes
complémentaires d'assurance maladie
alors cette prise en charge n'est pas
sans conséquence sur les tarifs des
contrats qui nécessairement auront
tendance à croître nous aurions pour
notre part préféré un mécanisme plus
solidaire via une revalorisation de la
consultation par la Sécurité Sociale et
le financement des nouveaux modes des
nouveaux de rémunération par elle une
mesure qui serait possible si de mesurer
efficace était prise pour mettre les
contre à l'équilibre quant au nouveau
mode de rémunération dont il s'agit ici
autant dire qu'il s'apparente à un
complément paiement à l'acte et non à
une réelle alternative à ce mode de
financement de type forfaitaire comme
nous l'appellons de nos vœux comme le
propose également le syndicat de
médecine générale enfin les modalités
d'application de cet article la parente
plus le prélèvement opéré sur les
organismes complémentaires à une
nouvelle taxe qu'à une véritable
contribution en faveur du développement
de nouveaux modes de rémunération au
point qu'on peut se demander si les
organismes complémentaires ne sont pas
ici transformés en collecteurs d'impôts
je tiens d'ailleurs à rappeler que la
Mutualité Française qui s'est prononcé
contre le projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale dans chacune des
instances officielles à laquelle elle
siège c'est également montré extrêmement
défavorable à ceux dispositif tout cela
nous conduit madame la ministre mes
chers collègues a proposé la suppression
de cette disposition merci chers
collègues l'amendement 294 rectifiés
présentés par Monsieur Ruquier
merci monsieur le Président Madame
ministre chers collègues monsieur
ministre mes chers collègues l'article 4
institut une participation des
organismes complémentaires d'assurance
maladie à la prise en charge de nouveaux
modes de rémunération des médecins
libéraux notamment le forfait maintien
traitant l'application de la venant
numéro 8 à la convention médicale le 25
octobre 2012 l'Union nationale les
organismes complémentaires d'assurance
maladie a signé établir numéro 8 dont
l'article 7 dispose que je cite les
organismes complémentaires souhaitent
participer à ce développement des
nouveaux modes de rémunération en
complétant le financement mis en place
par l'assurance maladie à hauteur de 150
millions d'euros notamment pour le
développement de forfaits pour les
médecins traitants or ces modalités de
financement de l'article 4 du projet de
loi des natures l'engagement pris par
Lucam et risque surtout d'entraîner le
blocage des négociations
conventionnelles à venir sur la foire il
permet l'Assurance Maladie de disposer
autoritairement des fonds librement
consentis par les opérateurs
complémentaires sans concentration avec
eux sur le fond il s'apparente d'un
nouvel taxation des complémentaires
contrairement à l'idée initiale d'un
financement d'une prestation de soins
aussi nous proposons de supprimer cet
article 4
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur quelle est la ville de la
générale que la ville de la Commission
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre une chers collègues dans trois
amendements donc 156 160 294 propose la
suppression de l'article 4 qui concerne
la participation des organismes
complémentaires au financement du
forfait médecin traitant chers collègues
autant nous pouvons nous rejoindre sur
le fait que les modalités de la
participation des eaux-cams au forfait
médecin traitant ne sont pas pleinement
satisfaisantes autant personne ne
propose en pratique une autre méthode or
j'insiste sur ce point les ocames se
sont bien engagés à verser 150 millions
d'euros à ce titre et je crois que
personne ne peut le contester depuis la
création de la Sécurité sociale les
organismes complémentaires prennent en
charge totalement ou partiellement le
ticket modérateur mais ceci ne
s'applique en pratique qu'au paiement à
l'acte il n'est pas complètement logique
que les ocames financent le ticket
modérateur
sur les actes et ne finance rien sur les
rémunérations sur objectif de santé
publique qui prennent une part
croissante supprimer donc l'article 4
sans rien proposer à la place
augmenterait le déficit de l'assurance
maladie maladie de 450 millions d'euros
pour les années 2013 un 2015 qui me
semble pas très judicieux il faut enfin
souligner que ce dispositif est
transitoire dans l'attente d'une
procédure pérenne point sur lequel
d'ailleurs j'ai souhaité assister par un
amendement que j'ai proposé à la
commission au vu de ces divers éléments
la commission a donné un avis
défavorable à cet amendement merci
Monsieur abattoir j'ai un madame les
ministres la vie de du gouvernement
sur ces trois amendements de quoi
s'agit-il contrairement à ce que j'ai
entendu lors de la négociation de
l'avenant 8 c'est-à-dire l'avenant sur
l'encadrement des dépassements
d'honoraires les organismes
complémentaires ce sont engagés à
apporter une contribution financière à
hauteur de 150 millions d'euros le débat
portait sur la manière de déterminer le
versement de ce versement enfin de cette
somme qui devait aller à la prise en
charge des du forfait de 5 euros versés
au médecin traitant annuellement je
tiens à signaler que ces sommes ont
d'ores et déjà commencer à être payé au
médecin traitant depuis le mois de
juillet dernier alors même que la
contribution des organismes
complémentaires elle n'a pas n'avait pas
encore été apportée le sujet consiste à
savoir comment la contribution des
organismes complémentaires peut être
identifier comme tel pour le
professionnel de santé et pour son
patient comment celui-ci peut-il savoir
que les organismes complémentaires
contribuent à cette prise en charge
améliorée de ce point de vue nous avons
besoin de la mise en place du tiers
payant qui je n'en doute pas fera
l'objet de débat entre nous pour que
cette traçabilité soit réalisée dans
l'attente la seule solution qui a été
trouvée c'est de procéder à ce versement
forfaitaire global qui va permettre la
mise en place de qui va permettre la
poursuite de ces versements aux
professionnels de santé mais pour le
gouvernement il s'agit bien d'un
dispositif temporaire transitoire qui a
vocation à s'éteindre dès lors que des
mesures de tiers payant permettront à la
contribution des complémentaires d'être
identifié c'est donc la raison ou les
raisons pour lesquelles le gouvernement
donne un avis défavorable à ses
amendements de suppression merci madame
la ministre pour explication de vote
monsieur Milou
merci monsieur le Président Madame
amiste
cet article 4 et ses amendes vise à
organiser l'application d'article 7 de
l'avenant numéro 8 à la Convention
nationale organisant les rapports entre
les médecins libéraux et l'assurance
maladie cette amenant comme il a été dit
avait prévu un engagement des organismes
complémentaires pour participer à
hauteur de 150 millions d'euros au
développement des nouveaux modes de
rémunération des médecins traitants afin
de compléter le financement mis en place
par l'assurance maladie obligatoire ce
dispositif rappelons-le devait pallier
de manière transitoire à l'absence à ce
jour la mécanisme de tiers-payant
intégral qui permettra comme la
dynaministre par la suite aux organismes
complémentaires de verser directement au
médecin traitant cette participation
cette contribution prendra alors la
forme d'un remboursement effectué par
chaque organisme concerné de la somme
correspondant à la participation qui
aurait été avancées par l'Assurance
Maladie pour le financement du forfait
par le médecin traitant
au regard de la complexité du dispositif
il ne semble pas
inutile de revenir sur son architecture
qui a été pensé disons-le franchement
dans la précipitation c'est d'ailleurs
pas un hasard si cette Avenant du 25
octobre 2012 n'a trouvé aucune
application à ce jour ce qui est
d'autant plus regrettable c'est que rien
n'a été précisé sur son application
concrète tout ce temps dans le flou
certains parlent de forfait tandis que
d'autres parlent de prélèvement
peut-être cela dépend-il en fin de
compte duquel chacun se trouve
comprendrez madame emis qu'avec cet
article vous donnez aux organismes
complémentaires le sentiment de
transformer cet engagement volontaire
qu'ils ont consenti à hauteur de 150
millions d'euros en une taxe versée
aveuglement à l'assurance maladie il est
trop facile
d'instrumentaliser la rémunération des
médecins traitants pour nous obliger à
voter un dispositif qui va asphyxier des
organismes complémentaires et des
responsabiliser les assurés avant que
même ne doit finalement supporter le
coût pour toutes ces raisons nous
voterons les amendements présentés par
nos collègues merci chers collègues je
savais pour explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre simplement pour replacer
effectivement le rôle du médecin
traitant dans le parcours de santé que
nous appelons tous de nos haroles
particulièrement importants dans les
différentes contributions qu'on a
amenées à ces conventions nationales et
notamment ça a été souligné par un de
nos collègues la limitation des
dépassements d'honoraires je rappelle
simplement quand même qu'il faut
relativiser les choses c'est parce que
il n'y a pas eu d'augmentation notamment
des spécialistes depuis des années que a
été autorisé les augmentations les
dépassements d'honoraires pour compenser
le manque à gagner flagrant de ces
praticiens que d'autre part il est prévu
un meilleur accès à la médecine
spécialisée certes nous l'appelons tous
de nos vœux sauf que tant qu'on
augmentera pas plus le numerus clausus
on aura un manque dramatique de médecins
spécialisés dans certains territoires et
toujours les mêmes territoires les
territoires les plus défavorisés
les territoires les plus reculés
rappelons quand même le déficit
structurel je dirais de médecins
spécialistes dans le domaine de la
gynécologie notamment de l'anesthésie
réanimation qui mettent en cause la
bonne marche d'un certain nombre de
services rappelez également que si on
veut un meilleur accès à la médecine
spécialisée il faudra donc revenir et
j'insiste madame la ministre sur ce
numéro ce clausus en ce qui concerne les
médecins adhérents au contrat d'accès
aux soins certes c'est intéressant c'est
bien ça ce sont des protocoles pour
faire en sorte que les malades soient
tous traités je dirais à la même
enseigne et soyez soigner selon des
protocoles bien établis de façon à ce
qu'ils aient un maximum de chances
d'être guéri mais également un maximum
de chances surtout de bénéficier de
mesures de prévention bien cadrées sauf
qu'il faut pas que cela
plateforme en contraintes
supplémentaires si on veut continuer à
avoir des médecins généralistes dans
l'ensemble des zones de ce territoire
car à force de contraintes on décourage
les bonnes volontés et derrière les
problèmes de rémunération ne deviennent
que secondaire mais si toutes ces
mesures ont la volonté de
responsabiliser
les praticiens
elles n'ont pas me semble-t-il elles
vont à l'encontre me semble-t-il de
votre volonté ensuite affichée de
généraliser le tiers payant je pense
qu'on a besoin maintenant d'une
responsabilisation des
usagers ça me paraît tout à fait
important on voit bien d'ailleurs les
difficultés des services des urgences
qui sont surchargés pas forcément pour
des pathologies relevant directement de
l'urgence mais bien souvent ça fait
partie des statistiques largement
affichées par les différents
gouvernements bien sous Jean parce que
les gens sont pressés et parce que il y
a le tiers payant le service est gratuit
donc on a aucune gêne à se déplacer pour
aller se faire soigner donc il faut
faire attentif à cela on voit bien
également la surconsommation des
médicaments on a eu déjà à débattre sur
ce sur ce problème là moi vous rappeler
que
ayant exercé pendant un certain nombre
d'années se formida métier de que le
médecin de famille j'allais
régulièrement dans les armoires des gens
pour voir les stocks de malades les
stocks de médicaments parlons avant de
avant de renouveler les avant de
renouveler les ordonnances si on est
toujours surpris bah oui les gens ne
payent pas ils savent pas combien ça
coûte et quand on leur dit véritablement
le prix de ce qu'ils ont en stock dans
leur armoire ils sont parfois surpris
donc je pense qu'il faut responsabiliser
les usagers en plus de responsabiliser
les médecins si on veut arriver à avoir
une médecine de qualité un coup sur
portable par la société c'est la raison
pour laquelle personnellement je
soutiendrai cet amendement merci cher
collègue je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explication de vote monsieur le
rapporteur général
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
l'annonce prévisible par les groupes de
la suppression donc de cet article me
paraît en fait étrange
j'ai sous les yeux le texte de l'avenant
numéro 8 elle a Convention nationale
organisant les rapports entre les
médecins libéraux et l'assurance maladie
signé le 26 juillet 2011 article 7 1 2 3
5e alinéa je lis les organismes
complémentaires souhaitent participer à
ce développement des nouveaux modes de
rémunération en complétant le
financement mis en place par l'assurance
maladie obligatoire à hauteur de 150
millions d'euros notamment par le
développement de forfait pour les
médecins traitants moi je voudrais en
appeler à l'esprit de responsabilité la
suppression de cet article aura pour
conséquence que c'est 150 millions ne
pourront pas être versées creusera donc
de 150 millions x 3 c'est-à-dire 450
millions de plus le déficit de la Caisse
d'Assurance Maladie pour les trois
années à venir je ne comprends pas si
discussions ils pouvaient y avoir sur
les modalités j'avais moi-même présenté
un certain amendements que nous en
soyons amenés à supprimer la totalité de
l'article
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
pas d'autres demandes d'explication de
vote j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe UMP sur les
amendements numéro 156 160 et 294
rectifié bises de suppression de
l'article 4 je vous rappelle que la
ville de la commission est défavorable
la vie du Gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invitais secrétaire à
procéder au dépouillement du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 46 sur les
amendements 156 160 et 294 rectifiés
Bliss nom de votants 347 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 346 pour l'adoption
208 compte 138 le Sénat a adopté et
l'article 4 et donc supprimer
alors sur l'article 5 j'ai une demande
de parole de Madame Cohen
oui je voudrais profiter de l'occasion
d'intervenir sur cet article 5 qui n'a
fait l'objet d'aucun débat à l'Assemblée
nationale pour vous interroger madame la
ministre sur l'existence des fonds dont
il est question ici et plus
particulièrement du fond de
modernisation des établissements de
santé publique et privés et de l'Office
national d'indemnisation des accidents
médicaux en effet cet article permet de
récupérer 26,8 millions d'euros de
crédit non utilisés par le fond de
modernisation des établissements de
santé publique et privé qui n'aurait pas
utilisé tous les crédits dont il
disposent le mécanisme est effectivement
prévu puisque la loi a mis en place une
procédure de déchéance annuelle pour les
crédits qui n'ont pas fait l'objet d'une
décision attributive de subvention ou
d'année agrément par une agence
régionale de santé dans un délai d'un an
à compter de la délégation de ces
crédits à ses agences donc par le fond
de modernisation des établissements de
santé publique et privées rien
d'étonnant ou de scandaleux en soi si ce
n'est que ce n'est pas la première fois
que ce fond ne consomme pas tous ces
crédits ce qui nous étonne puisque même
si son parrain son paramètre a été
redéfini depuis la création du fond
d'intervention régionale il lui incombe
toujours de financer ou du moins de
participer au financement de mesures
nationales en particulier les
investissements faisant l'objet d'un
financement national les crédits peuvent
dès lors être mobilisés pour financer
des mesures d'amélioration des
conditions de travail des personnels des
établissements de santé des mesures de
modernisation des établissements de
santé ou encore financer
l'accompagnement des hôpitaux en faveur
de la performance hospitalière des
missions effectivement importantes pour
les personnels comme pour le
développement des hôpitaux je peine donc
à comprendre comment ces sommes peuvent
ne pas être utilisés alors même que les
agents des hôpitaux que nous rencontrons
tous les personnels d'ailleurs des
hôpitaux ne cessent de nous dire combien
ils sont en attente de telle mesure à
l'inverse vous augmentez la dotation de
l'ONIAM pour la porter en 2013 à 139
millions d'euros au motif que
l'accélération des délais de traitement
de l'Office aurait conduit à la purement
d'un plus grand nombre de dossiers
qu'est-ce qu'on fait cela va donc dans
l'intérêt des patients ce qui ne peut
que nous satisfaire toutefois madame la
ministre vous savez que depuis la crise
du médiateur le miam a en charge
l'indemnisation des patients ayant
consommé du banc fluorex or il s'avère
que les dossiers sont traités avec
lenteur et qu'un grand nombre de
dossiers notamment pour lesquels les
moins graves sont systématiquement
écartés de la procédure d'indemnisation
cela inquiète la pneumologue Irène
Frachon à l'origine de l'affaire du
Médiator qui récemment encore déclarait
nous avons confronté le résultat à ceux
des récentes études épidémiologiques
ciblées sur l'effet du Médiator cela ne
colle pas par ailleurs la procédure
d'indemnisation prévoit que le niAme est
autorisé
engager des actions
récursoires contre le laboratoire
exploitant lorsque l'Office indemise une
victime or comme l'avait fort à propos
relevé notre collègue françois Autain il
ne s'agit là que d'une faculté laisser à
l'ONIAM ce qui sous-entend que les
actions récursoires ne sont pas
automatique je voudrais donc savoir où
nous en sommes aujourd'hui je vous
remercie merci chers collègues je n'ai
pas d'autres demandes de parole nous
votons sur l'article 5 pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien lever
la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre va bien
lever la main abstention il est adopté
amendement sur l'article 6 l'amendement
322 présenté par Madame la Ministre pour
le gouvernement
oui monsieur le Président cet amendement
a pour objectif de prendre en compte les
dernières données connues sur l'objectif
national de dépenses de l'assurance
maladie et
compte tenu de ces éléments nous pouvons
considérer que l'exécution de la dame
pour l'année 2013 se situerait à 650
millions d'euros
en deçà de l'objectif qui a été voté
dans le cadre de la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale et non pas à 500
millions d'euros comme c'était
initialement prévu lors de la
construction de cet objectif national et
donc cette amendement a pour objectif de
tenir compte de cet élément
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues extrêmement
combien d'années proposent de modifier à
la marge des prévisions de dépenses et
le solde du régime général et des
régimes obligatoires de base pour 2013
l'ajustement proposé vise à tenir compte
des dernières données connues concernant
l'évolution de Van Damme à savoir donc
une diminution de 150 millions d'euros
des dépenses de soins de ville la
commission des affaires sociales
donnaient un avis favorable à cet
amendement merci Monsieur aventure
générale expiation de vote Monsieur
Alain Milot
oui monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre mes chers collègues cet
article 6 du présent projet de loi a
pour objet de réviser donc les tableaux
d'équilibre des différentes branches de
la sécurité sociale pour 2013 c'est
rectification traduisent un problème
d'appréciation récurrent de la part du
gouvernement sur la situation économique
de notre pays une erreur dans la
prévision de croissance fixée à 08 % du
PIB en FSS 2013 alors qu'en réalité elle
atteindra péniblement 0,1% dans ce
contexte de perte de recettes due au
manque de croissance et de montée du
chômage l'ensemble des régimes
obligatoires de base affiche un déficit
pour 2013 de 14,2 milliards d'euros au
lieu des 12,8 initialement prévus par la
loi de financement pour 2013 ces
chiffres doivent nous conduire à engager
une réflexion plus profonde sur ce qui
constitue l'architecture de notre
système de financement en matière de
sécurité sociale en effet
nous partageons tous la conception
solidaire qui caractérise notre système
et qui permet à tous nos concitoyens
d'être égaux devant l'accès aux soins
pour autant si notre fiscalité a pour
objectif de réduire les inégalités
sociales encore faut-il avant de
réfléchir à la redistribution des
richesses que l'impôt soit cohérent dans
son prélèvement il n'est pas possible de
taxer tout et n'importe quoi ni de le
faire n'importe comment même la
Commission européenne nous avait indiqué
l'importance de déplacer la charge
fiscale du travail vers l'environnement
et la consommation en d'autres termes
elle nous incite à ne pas céder en
permanence à la facilité pour financer
notre sécurité sociale or ce n'est pas
la voix que vous suivez puisque comme
d'habitude vous faites reposer l'effort
sur le travail récemment le président de
la République avait fait mine de
promettre aux Français une grande
réforme fiscale pour plus de lisibilité
aujourd'hui nous voyons bien il
s'agissait de parole en l'air voyez un
peu l'incohérence d'une politique
fiscale qui devait d'abord consister à
faire financer les retraites par la CSG
et qui est maintenant censé financer
notre système de protection sociale par
de nouveaux prélèvements sur le travail
certains avaient proposé d'engager une
réflexion sur la nécessité de rechercher
d'autres ressources c'est une voie que
nous aurions dû explorer je suis
convaincu qu'à terme nous ne pourrons
plus interroger car il nous paraît
suicidaire d'asseoir toujours plus le
financement de notre système de
protection sociale sur le travail à
moins de vouloir ouvertement et
complètement le décourager tarir la
richesse de notre pays et finalement
provoquer son effondrement total nous
voterons donc contre cet article merci
cher collègue pour explication de vote
oui cet article ajusté par l'amendement
gouvernemental a pour objet de réviser
les tableaux d'équilibre des différentes
branches de la sécurité sociale pour
l'observation que nous avons faite sur
l'article 1 quant audition dans
lesquelles la droite avait obtenu en
2012 une réduction des déficits sociaux
pourraient malheureusement s'appliquer
ici puisque la réduction des déficits
est obtenu moins en raison d'un
accroissement de ressources solidaires
qu'en raison de l'application d'une
politique de rigueur dont les hôpitaux
ont été notamment les premières victimes
de la même manière si le déficit du fond
solidarité vieillesse a été ralenti
c'est grâce à l'instauration dans le
précédent pfss de la taxe sur les
retraites dans le Produit lui a été
dédié alors même que l'objectif de cette
taxe est logiquement de préparer
financer la future réforme de la perte
d'autonomie qui plus est même si les
déficits ont effectivement été réduits
je tiens à signaler que le déficit
demeure supérieure à ce qui prévu et ce
alors même qu'il n'y a eu aucun dérapage
aucune hausse des dépenses de santé même
faut-il rappeler que tous les crédits
votés n'ont pas été utilisés c'est donc
bien du côté des choix économiques et
sociaux du gouvernement qu'il faut
rechercher les causes de ces
déséquilibres tout d'abord les
prévisions de croissance sur lesquelles
le gouvernement fonde ces pays les
fesses sont totalement déconnectés de la
situation réelle l'an dernier le
gouvernement nous promettait une
croissance de 0,809 et une importante
augmentation de la masse salariale
aujourd'hui avec le recul la réalité
apparaît très différente puisque la
croissance à péniblement atteint les 0
1% que nous avons frôlé en raison des
politiques de rigueur la récession nous
analysons aussi cet échec comme le refus
de prendre en compte les amendements que
nous proposons faveur d'un financement
juste et équilibré de notre protection
sociale c'est parce que vous refusez de
moduler les cotisations sociales de
telle sorte qu'elle soit plus lourde sur
les pourvoyeurs d'emplois précaires
moins lourdes sur les employeurs qui
favorisent l'emploi et les salaires que
les contraires précaires et atypiques
augmentent c'est parce que vous refusez
d'interdire les licenciements boursiers
que les entreprises qui réalisent des
bénéfices et distribuent des dividendes
licencie c'est parce que vous refusez de
sanctionner financièrement les
employeurs qui pratiquent des
discriminations salariales à l'égard des
femmes que ces dernières vont continuer
à percevoir des salaires inférieurs
nettement à ceux des hommes et donc à
moins cotisés pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe CRC votera contre cet article
merci chers collègues monsieur
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
en prolongement de l'intervention de
notre collègue Alain Milon qui l'a fait
aussi avec beaucoup de talents et de
connaissances
mais simplement moi je verrai plutôt le
côté à la fois financier et technique
parce que c'est vrai que cet amendement
présenté par Madame la Ministre
au nom du au nom du gouvernement et mais
c'est vrai que dans les
les budgets précédents du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
nous avions toujours aussi quel que soit
les ministres les ministres antérieurs
il y avait aussi ces tableaux
rectificatifs qui nous présentaient ces
tableaux à la fois pédagogique mais qui
montre quand même des montants
financiers très importants puisque en
prévision de recettes
449,4 millions d'euros objectif de
dépenses 463,6 millions
milliards d'euros donc on a quand même
des chiffres réellement très conséquents
que qu'il convient aussi d'apprécier
parce que j'irai certes avec un solde de
moins 14,2 milliards d'euros je dirais
ça nous interpelle alors après et malgré
aussi je respecte tout à fait aussi les
les interventions de qualité du
rapporteur général qui ont commission
j'irai donne une explication aussi très
pédagogique de de l'évolution de
aussi différents chiffres en masse
financières bon c'est sûr que l'objectif
de dépenses 463 milliards d'euros c'est
des chiffres vraiment qui nous
interpellent et qui nous font réellement
réfléchir donc pour au niveau la branche
maladie sont plus de 189 millions
d'euros alors après on peut interpréter
ajuster
bouger les les chiffres ont on peut on
peut on peut comprendre que aucun
système n'est parfait aucune règle et
après qu'il faut se faut faire évoluer
ces chiffres mais je partagerai tout à
fait avec les explications de notre
collègue Alain Milon bon écoutez je
ne voterai pas non plus cette amendement
merci cher collègue je n'ai pas d'autres
demandes d'explication de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement
veuille bien lever la main
nous sommes sur l'amendement
1 2 3
merci que ceux qui sont contrevent bien
lever la main
abstention
l'amendement n'est pas adopté de votons
sur l'article 6 pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet article veuille
bien lever la main
merci à vie contraire
abstention l'amande l'article n'est pas
adopté
normalement sur l'article 7 j'ai une
demande de parole après
pardon j'ai une demande de parle de
Madame Pasquier
merci monsieur le Président à l'occasion
de son intervention générale mon
collègue Dominique Watrin a rappelé que
notre groupe c'était opposé à la
fixation de la dame pour 2013 que nous
jugeions insuffisants cet article revoit
l'ondame pour 2013 à la baisse puisque
les dépenses d'assurance maladie se sont
établies un niveau inférieur d'environ
500 millions d'euros est-ce qui avait
été prévu si ce résultat a été
effectivement partie du au médecin qui
aura respecté leurs engagements en
matière de réduction des prescriptions
il est également la conséquence d'une
pression financière importante sur les
établissements publics de santé qui je
ne répéterai pas ce que j'ai dit au
préalable en fait ce qu'elle dit mon
collègue dans la discussion générale en
supporter une campagne tarifaire d'une
grande vigueur aggravant ainsi leurs
difficultés mais c'est également la
conséquence d'un mouvement
particulièrement préoccupant en
constante progression de renoncement des
plus faibles des les pauvre des plus
éloignées du système de santé
et des soins comme vous le savez selon
l'INSEE en 2010
16,2% de la population métropolitaine
âgée de 18 à 74 ans déclare avoir
renoncé à des soins pour des raisons de
financières au cours des 12 derniers
mois c'est le cas de 32,6% des individus
non couverts par une complémentaire la
structure d'âge et sexe comparable et
bénéficiaires de la CMU complémentaire
sont
20,4% à renoncer quand se protéger par
une couverture privée
114,7%. les mesures prises dans ce pdfss
ne sont pas de nature inversée cette
situation puisque vous concentrez vos
efforts sur les mesures d'accompagnement
des déplacements d'honoraires quand il
faut les interdire et vous voulez coûte
que coûte développer les mutuelles y
compris la CMU ou la CMUC quand
l'urgence est d'efficacité suppose de
garantir pour toutes et tous une prise
en charge à 100% par la Sécurité sociale
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe CRC
votera contre cet article merci chers
collègues monsieur bidon
merci monsieur le Président Madame Miss
mes chers collègues cet article 7 donc
qui est rectifie les données relatives
de l'ONDAM de l'ensemble des régimes
obligatoires de base ainsi que celle
relative à ses sous-objectifs au titre
de l'année 2013 sur la base des données
qui nous sont communiquées nous nous
réjouissons que les objectifs fixés
étaient respectés avec un niveau de
dépenses d'assurance maladie inférieur
d'environ 500 millions d'euros à ce
qu'il y avait été prévu cette réussite
n'est pas seulement conjoncturelle égard
à l'absence d'épidémie importante au
cours de l'année qui s'achève c'est
aussi le résultat de la bonne volonté
affichée des médecins qui ont veillé un
établir que les prescriptions
nécessaires en effet nous observons avec
satisfaction que les dépenses de
médicaments ont été réduites grâce
notamment à l'action des médecins de
ville qui ont respecté leur engagement
en matière de maîtrise médicalisée je ne
peux m'empêcher toutefois de rappeler le
volontar de la précédente majorité
lorsqu'elle a vécu à cœur de maîtriser
les dépenses de santé néanmoins je pense
que le gouvernement devrait redonner de
l'oxygène aux soins de ville notamment
en s'appuyant encore plus sur le
développement d'un chirurgie ambulatoire
qui pourrait générer jusqu'à 5 milliards
d'euros d'économie supplémentaires selon
les estimations de la Cour des comptes
la médecine de ville libérale est prête
à assumer le transfert de l'activité
hospitalière pour peu qu'on lui en donne
les moyens je vous en remercie merci
cher collègue alors nous arrivons à
l'amendement 323 présenté par Madame la
Ministre pour le gouvernement
oui monsieur le Président c'est
amendement comme un article précédent
l'article 6 visa tirer les conséquences
de du constat que les économies
réalisées sur l'ONDAM en 2013 ont été
plus importantes que prévu 250 millions
d'euros
merci madame le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général la ville de la
Commission
ce président madame la ministre mais
chaque règle a envie de la Commission et
favorable merci pas de demande
d'explication de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement et
bien lever la main
merci que ceux qui sont contrevent bien
lever la main
merci abstention l'amendement n'est pas
adopté nous votons sur l'article 7 pas
de demande d'explication de vote que
ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter veuille
bien lever la main
merci avis contraire
l'article n'est pas adopté je vais
mettre voix l'ensemble de la deuxième
partie du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2014 y
a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote
je mets donc aux voix l'ensemble de la
deuxième partie que ce qui soit adopter
va bien lever la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre le bien
lever la main
merci abstention elle n'est pas adoptée
je suis
saisie d'une demande de priorité de la
Commission sur l'article 12 terres que
nous discuterons au début de la
troisième partie selon l'article 44
alinéa 6 de notre règlement la priorité
est de droit quand elle est demandée par
la Commission saisie au fond madame la
Présidente c'est ce que vous vouliez
dire
merci la vie du gouvernement
très bien la priorité est donc ordonnée
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance il reste 274 amendements examinés
sur ce texte l'ordre du jour du mercredi
13 novembre 2013 à 14h30 et le soir
suite du projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2014 la séance
est levée
voilà les sénateurs rendent donc rejeté
la deuxième partie du texte consacrée au
compte pour l'année 2013 ils vont
reprendre leur discussion cet après-midi
à l'article 12 TER consacré à la clause
de désignation une clause a priori assez
technique mais qui risque d'être
vivement discuté puisqu'elle vise à
rendre obligatoire la même mutuelle pour
les entreprises d'une même branche
professionnelle et cela sous peine de
payer une taxe supplémentaire c'est une
mesure qui est à l'origine du mouvement
des bonnets jaunes le mouvement des
petites mutuelles qui manifestaient hier
devant le Sénat vous pouvez bien sûr
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site public sénat.fr
rendez-vous de l'actualité parlementaire
cet après-midi donc toujours sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 à 16h30